[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Herzlich willkommen in Hogwarts!
Ja.
Heute traue ich mich tatsächlich endlich an die
Harry-Potter-Torte.
Die letzten Jahre habe ich es euch
wirklich schon versprochen.
Und ich glaube, bei mir hat sich schon so ein bisschen
ein Druck aufgebaut.
Denn ich glaube, eure Erwartungshaltung
ist schon ziemlich hoch.
Ich habe folgende Situation:
Ich möchte eine Harry-Potter-Torte machen,
die natürlich thematisch gut dazu passt.
Sie soll aber auch gut schmecken.
Das heißt, ich mache jetzt eine Motivtorte,
die eben auch nachmachbar ist.
Ich meine, es gibt Tortenkünstler,
Cake Decorators,
die einfach wochenlang an einer Torte arbeiten,
die krassesten Zuckerfiguren machen.
Aber so was kann man zum einen zu Hause nicht nachmachen
und zum anderen ist es halt irgendwann
einfach nicht mehr essbar und genießbar.
Also mache ich eine Torte,
die hoffentlich euren Erwartungen entspricht.
Ich nehme euch jetzt einfach mit.
Denn momentan weiß ich noch nicht
so ganz genau, was ich mache.
Ich habe schon eine kleine Vorstellung.
Aber ihr seht schon,
wir haben uns schon mächtig ins Zeug gelegt,
dass wir alle so ein bisschen in Harry Potter reinkommen.
Ich muss auch dazusagen,
ich habe die Bücher nicht gelesen.
Bitte steinigt mich nicht.
Ich habe sie noch nicht gelesen.
Ich weiß noch, als Kind, da war ich in der fünften Klasse
– ja, so alt bin ich schon.
1997 kam das erste Buch raus
und 99 haben alle meine Freunde das Buch gelesen
und ich habe es nicht gekriegt.
Also konnte ich es nicht lesen.
Ich
– mich trifft keine Schuld.
Aber irgendwann kamen die Filme.
Die habe ich dann geguckt.
Wir waren sogar damals in der Dreier-Nacht,
also im Kino alle drei Filme nacheinander.
Nicht, was ihr jetzt denkt.
Und
ja...
Aber ich bin wirklich
schon ein bisschen aus dem Thema raus.
Aber Josh und Sarah, die sind voll die Harry-Potter-Fans.
Darf ich das so sagen?
Okay, Josh nicht. Aber Sarah ist voll der Freak.
Murat habe ich auch schon weggeschickt,
um ein paar Accessoires zu holen.
Und die zwei, die helfen mir ein bisschen auf die Sprünge.
Ja.
Also ich habe mir jetzt vorgestellt:
Ich mache zum einen den sprechenden Hut.
Der entscheidet ja darüber,
in welches Haus man einzieht.
Dann mache ich eine mitt-
– ach so, es soll eine dreistöckige Torte werden.
Ich habe mir schon einiges vorgenommen die nächsten Tage.
Dann mache ich eine mittlere Torte.
Die soll das Harry-Potter-Logo haben
und so ein bisschen eine Betonoptik.
Und das untere Stockwerk, da, habe ich mir gedacht,
orientiere ich mich so ein bisschen an Gleis 9 3/4
und mache das eben noch.
Ja.
Und dann gucke ich einfach, was passiert.
Und
dann legen wir einfach los.
Also ich mache mir ein paar Überlegungen,
nehme euch ein bisschen mit,
wie ich was überlege,
warum ich welche Zutat nehmen
oder wie ich die Torte mache.
Und dann
habe ich eine Anleitung hoffentlich für euch.
Ich hoffe es!
Also die machen wir außen grau.
Und dann ist hier Gold.
Dann haben wir noch den goldenen Schnatz.
Entweder sitzt der dann hier
– oh, der Stift ist leer.
Oh, der Stift ist auch leer.
Der ist tatsächlich noch aus meiner Schulzeit.
Kein Wunder, ist der leer.
Der ist auch leer!
Mein Gott!
[Musik]
Und diese Torte mache ich jetzt
mit einem neuen Geschmack
und zwar Apple Crumble.
Da mache ich eine Apfelfüllung,
einen Crumble dazu
und eine passende Buttercreme.
Ja.
Und der Hut, der wird
aus Schokolade.
Das passt am besten.
Dann habe ich eine Schokotorte,
eine Apfeltorte
und da unten mache ich jetzt
Gleis 9 3/4.
Da muss ich mir auch kurz Bilder anschauen.
Gleis 9 3...
[Musik]
Und die ist ja so ein bisschen rotbraun von außen.
Und da
fällt mir jetzt so
– kennt ihr dieses Kaugummi?
Dieses scharfe von
– ist das Wrigley's?
Mit Zimt.
Ich mache
>> JOSH: 5 Gum war das.
>> SALLY: 5 Gum?
Nee, dieses
– am Kaugummiautomaten
haben wir das früher immer gekauft.
Das war so mit Zimt und scharf und dunkelrot.
Ich glaube, ich mache was mit Zimt und Kirsche.
Ja, das fällt mir jetzt so spontan ein.
Zimt und Kirsche.
Was backe ich denn zuerst?
Das wird ja ein Jahrhundertprojekt!
Also zuerst einmal würde ich jetzt sagen,
rein aus zeitlichen Gründen
würde ich jetzt einfach die Böden backen,
das heißt Schokoböden hier
und ich zeige euch gleich,
was ich hier für Böden mache.
Ich überlege mir kurz einen Teig
und dann geht es an die Zutatenfahrt.
Für den Schokoladenkuchen nehme ich
320 Gramm Butter,
200 Gramm Zartbitterschokolade,
200 Gramm Zucker und eine Prise Salz,
acht Eier,
200 Gramm Mehl,
eineinhalb Teelöffel Backpulver,
30 Gramm Kakao
und etwas Tonka Wonka.
Das ist jetzt der Schokoladenkuchen für saftige Motivtorten.
Den nehme ich jetzt nämlich für den Hut,
damit ich den Hut einfach
später schön in Form schneiden kann.
Ich habe ein bisschen den Zucker reduziert.
Denn die Torte wird süß genug.
Jetzt nehme ich erst mal die Butter.
Die kommt in den Topf
und kann schon mal geschmolzen werden.
Auf niedriger Stufe bitte.
In der Schüssel hier kann ich schon mal die Eier verrühren.
Da gebe ich auch schon mal Zucker und Salz dazu.
Andersrum.
Salz war das Kleine, Zucker das Große.
Das verrühre ich jetzt schon mal hier.
Und das wird jetzt hier gar nicht schaumig gerührt,
sondern wirklich nur verrührt.
Das Ganze ist nämlich kein lockerer Teig,
sondern eher ein fester, aber dafür ein saftiger.
Und dadurch lässt er sich eben später
dann auch gut in Form schneiden.
Was für Chocoholics.
Sobald die Butter dann flüssig ist,
könnt ihr den Herd ausschalten
und die Schokolade dazu geben.
Dann schmilzt die Schokolade nämlich in der Restwärme
und die Masse wird nicht zu heiß.
Dann kann ich sie nämlich gleich weiter benutzen.
Das kann jetzt hier schon mal schmelzen.
Ich kann hier die trockenen Zutaten noch verrühren
beziehungsweise alle in ein Sieb hineinfüllen.
[Musik]
Yay!
Alles geschmolzen.
Okay, ich hätte einen Topf mit einem Stiel nehmen sollen.
Na ja.
Ich kriege das auch so hin.
Und jetzt kommt diese warme Masse
direkt zur Eiermasse.
Deswegen darf sie auch nicht
zu heiß sein.
Sonst habt ihr nämlich Schokorührei.
Und hier passt halt jetzt echt Tonka Wonka
richtig gut dazu.
Mh.
Das ist bald leer.
Und dann kommen hier einfach
nur noch die trockenen Zutaten dazu
und werden ganz schnell eingerührt.
[Musik]
Wenn ich jetzt nur den sprechenden Hut
als Torte machen würde,
würde ich das Ganze etwas größer machen
und einfach in Backringen backen.
So habe ich nämlich schon eine runde Form.
Ich mache es jetzt aber so,
da der Hut im Durchmesser bei mir jetzt 30 cm hat,
aber nur dieser Hut-
– ist das der Schaft?
Was ist denn das beim Hut?
So dieses...
Dieses Ding hier soll bei mir 30 cm im Durchmesser haben
und der Hut an sich oben 15 cm.
Ich habe es nämlich an einem Bild
so ausgemessen proportional.
Und die Höhe sind dann auch 30 cm.
Und so kleine Backringe habe ich nicht.
Also backe ich das Ganze jetzt hier in einem Backblech
und steche es später einfach aus.
[Musik]
Und jetzt kann er schon gebacken werden.
Während der Kuchen im Ofen ist,
mache ich mich schon mal an den nächsten Kuchen.
Das wird nämlich das zweite Stockwerk,
die Harry-Potter-Torte sozusagen,
diese Betonoptik.
Da mache ich jetzt einen Walnusskuchen.
Und der wird ja später mit Apple Crumble gefüllt.
Probiere ich jetzt einfach mal aus.
Dafür nehme ich
vier Eier,
200 Gramm Zucker,
eine Prise Salz,
drei Tropfen Karamellaroma,
jeweils 200 Gramm Buttermilch und Sonnenblumenöl,
130 Gramm Walnüsse,
– die mahle ich gleich noch –
300 Gramm Mehl
und zwei Teelöffel Backpulver.
Und die gleichen Zutaten habe ich
hier im Hintergrund noch mal.
Denn ich backe das Ganze in einem 25-cm-Ring
und ich will die Torte schon etwas höher haben.
Deswegen backe ich jetzt einfach gleich zwei Böden.
Und hier ist es auch wirklich supereinfach.
Ihr gebt zuerst Eier, Salz, Zucker und Karamell
in eine Rührschüssel.
[Musik]
Der Karamell passt da jetzt wirklich supergut dazu.
Und jetzt hier die Zutaten einfach schön cremig verrühren.
Den Ofen habe ich bereits
auf 170°C Ober-/Unterhitze vorgeheizt.
Und im Hintergrund rühre ich schon mal den zweiten Kuchen.
[Musik]
Der ist jetzt fertig.
Der darf jetzt hier abkühlen.
Der Ofen ist bereit für den nächsten.
Und hier kommen jetzt die Flüssigkeiten rein.
Die werden jetzt ganz kurz eingerührt.
Und hier kann ich schon mal Backpulver und Mehl
in mein Sieb geben.
Jetzt gebe ich hier noch die Walnüsse rein,
die mir fast aus der Hand geflogen wären.
Mehl und Backpulver.
Und ein Deckel.
Und das wird jetzt nur noch ganz kurz untergehoben
beziehungsweise eingerührt.
Und weil der Teig eben etwas flüssiger ist,
musste ich die Tortenringe
einfach in Backpapier einschlagen.
Der wird jetzt hier direkt eingefüllt.
Und weil eben die doppelte Menge
für einen Backring zu viel wäre,
mache ich das eben auf zwei Mal,
das heißt hinten der eine Teig,
hier der andere Teig.
Und natürlich dann einfach nacheinander backen
oder in zwei Backöfen.
Also in einem Backofen mit Heißluft funktioniert das nicht.
Da werden sie trocken.
Und wenn ihr nur einen habt,
macht sie wirklich schön nacheinander.
[Musik]
Ofen eins,
Ofen zwei.
Und danach geht es an den dritten Kuchen.
[Musik]
Weiter geht es jetzt mit dem dritten Kuchen.
Das ist der Zimtkuchen.
Für den Zimtteig nehme ich
fünf Eier,
250 Gramm Zucker,
eine Prise Salz,
jeweils 250 Gramm Sonnenblumenöl und Buttermilch,
500 Gramm Mehl,
ein Päckchen Backpulver
– das sind drei Teelöffel –
und drei Esslöffel Zimt.
Und da bitte unbedingt darauf achten,
den Ceylon-Zimt zu nehmen
und nicht den günstigen Cassia-Zimt.
Den günstigen Cassia-Zimt
darf man nämlich nicht überdosieren.
Und deswegen lieber den Ceylon-Zimt.
Ich probiere es jetzt mal mit drei Esslöffeln.
Vielleicht ist es auch zu viel.
Ich probiere einfach später.
Also das ist jetzt die Menge für einen 30-cm-Ring.
Ich habe hier hinten wieder die gleiche Menge,
sodass ich einfach zwei Kuchen backen kann.
Die Zubereitung ist genau gleich
wie beim Kuchen gerade eben.
Eier, Zucker und Salz richtig schaumig rühren.
Danach die zwei Flüssigkeiten dazu,
die trockenen Zutaten dazu,
alles unterrühren und einfüllen.
[Musik]
Der sieht so richtig lecker nach Zimtcreme aus.
Bei uns gibt es jetzt Mittagessen für alle.
Und zwar
einen mediterranen Nudelsalat mit Rucola,
vegan.
Gemüsepfanne.
Hier haben wir noch Naturreis
und Gyros,
Rindergyros.
Und das essen wir jetzt.
Und in der Zeit kann ja hier schon mal
– können alle Kuchen abkühlen.
Und alle helfen mit.
[Musik]
Die Kuchenböden sind abgekühlt.
Und ihr wünscht euch ja immer
für meine Torten besondere Füllungen.
Daher bekommt jetzt auch jede Torte eine andere Füllung.
Jetzt fange ich zuerst mal mit dem Hut an.
Dafür verwende ich
100 Gramm Zartbitterschokolade,
– die habe ich bereits aufgeteilt in zwei Drittel, ein Drittel –
50 Gramm gehackte Mandeln
und 50 Gramm Salzbrezeln.
Ich schmelze jetzt zuerst mal die zwei Drittel Kuvertüre.
Und hier kann ich die Salzbrezeln schon mal zerkleinern.
Wenn ihr keinen salzigen Crunch in der Torte haben wollt,
könnt ihr auch Cornflakes nehmen
oder, wenn ihr ganz auf die Arbeit verzichten wollt,
einfach Choco Crossies.
Und sobald die zwei Drittel geschmolzen sind,
einfach vom Wasserbad herunternehmen
und das restliche Drittel einrühren.
So wird die Kuvertüre einfach temperiert,
das heißt wieder heruntergekühlt,
und sie wird schön fest und glänzt
und bekommt keinen grauen Schleier.
Dann wird alles gemeinsam verrührt.
Jetzt sollten einfach die kompletten Brezeln mit der Kuvertüre
schön umhüllt sein.
Denn dann bleibt es auch schön knackig.
Und hier habe ich jetzt ein kleines Alublech,
eine Dauerbackfolie drauf.
Das kommt jetzt hier drauf
und darf dann in den Kühlschrank.
Und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal die Apfelfüllung machen für die zweite Torte.
[Musik]
Für die Apfelfüllung nehme ich ein Kilo Äpfel,
– da habe ich jetzt Elstar Äpfel,
die schäle ich auch gleich
und messe das geschälte Gewicht –
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
30 Gramm Stärke,
20 Gramm Zucker,
100 Gramm Apfelsaft
und den Saft einer Zitrone.
Die Äpfel schäle ich jetzt,
entkerne sie und schneide sie dann in Würfel.
Und mit der Apfelschale könnt ihr zum Beispiel
einen richtig leckeren Apfeltee machen.
Einfach mit heißem Wasser übergießen
und dann entweder süßen oder nicht süßen,
so wie es euch am besten schmeckt.
Bei den Äpfeln habe ich jetzt
doch nur 600 Gramm genommen.
Denn ich glaube,
das wird ansonsten einfach zu viel.
Ich will ja noch Crumble machen.
Also hier kommt jetzt noch der Zitronensaft dazu,
damit die Äpfel nicht braun werden
und auch für die Säure.
Und dann kann ich jetzt hier die Stärke
mit dem Apfelsaft verrühren.
[Musik]
Das kommt dann auch hier dazu.
Und etwas Vanilleextrakt.
Und, wer mag, noch ein bisschen Zucker.
Die Masse könnt ihr dann hier auf dem Herd einfach
so ein bisschen aufkochen lassen und einkochen lassen,
bis die Äpfel etwas weich werden.
Ich gebe da jetzt am Anfang noch einen Deckel gleich drauf
und kann in der Zwischenzeit
auch schon mal die Kirschfüllung machen
für den dritten Kuchen.
Das wird lecker!
Für die Kirschfüllung nehme ich
300 Gramm Kirschen aus dem Tiefkühlfach,
50 Gramm Zucker,
20 Gramm Stärke
und 20 Gramm Wasser.
Die Kirschen habe ich jetzt bereits auftauen lassen.
Ein bisschen kalt sind sie noch,
aber größtenteils, hoffe ich, schon mal aufgetaut.
Und die püriere ich jetzt
mit dem Zucker
und Wasser,
was ich aus Versehen verschüttet habe.
Stärke kommt auch gleich dazu.
Und wenn ihr gefrorene Kirschen nehmt,
habt ihr wirklich diese wunderschöne Farbe,
nicht wie die aus dem Glas.
[Musik]
Das kommt jetzt hier in den Topf,
darf auch aufkochen, bis es ein bisschen eindickt.
Und dann habe ich schon
die dritte Füllung fertig.
Dafür nehme ich
100 Gramm Butter,
100 Gramm Zucker,
eine Prise Salz
und 200 Gramm Mehl
und, wenn ihr möchtet, noch Karamellaroma.
Und das Ganze verknetet ihr einfach mit den Händen.
Jetzt kurz durchkneten zu Streuseln.
Und dann kann ich jetzt schon mal
in der Zwischenzeit die Buttercremes zubereiten.
Wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr auch eine Ganache machen
für die einzelnen Torten.
Ist ein bisschen einfacher,
weil eine Ganache nur aus Sahne und Schokolade besteht.
Aber ich muss euch eins sagen:
Meine Buttercremes schmecken wirklich nicht so buttrig,
sondern eher schokoladig oder fruchtig,
je nachdem, wie man sie eben zubereitet.
Und ich glaube, bei den meisten...
Ich glaube, bei allen drei
mache ich jetzt gleich eine Buttercreme.
Vielleicht entscheide ich mich noch spontan um,
aber ich fange schon mal damit an.
Und die Streusel könnt ihr jetzt so direkt auf das Blech geben.
[Musik]
Hier sind die Zutaten für die Schokobuttercreme
für den sprechenden Hut.
Denn, wenn ich den sprechenden Hut sehe,
dann ist der für mich innen und außen Schoko pur.
Da freut sich der Marcel.
Ja.
Sechs Eier,
200 Gramm Zucker,
einen halben Teelöffel Salz,
450 Gramm weiche Butter,
300 Gramm Zartbitterschokolade
und Tonka Wonka.
Mensch, Josh!
Dass du nicht hast lachen müssen bei der Butter!
>> JOSH: Damit werden doch die Bleche eingefettet.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich bin ein sehr butterreicher Haushalt.
Ich esse ja die Torte nicht allein!
Die isst der Marcel.
Also bei der Buttercreme ist jetzt ganz wichtig,
dass die Eier mit dem Zucker und Salz
erhitzt werden auf 70°C.
Entweder nehmt ihr dafür einen Topf,
stellt eine Schüssel drüber und unten drunter natürlich Wasser,
also ein Wasserbad,
lasst das Wasser kochen
und rührt dann mit dem Handrührgerät
die Eier-Zucker-Masse für zehn Minuten
– dann ist sie wirklich auch schon schön erhitzt –
oder ihr nehmt eine Küchenmaschine mit Hitzefunktion.
Ich würde es euch jetzt wirklich supergern
auf dem Herd zeigen,
aber ich habe noch so viel vor mir
und ich will heute irgendwann noch fertig werden,
zumindest mit der Füllung,
dass ich das jetzt hier direkt bei 70°C mache.
Also hier Butter
– nicht Butter –
Eier, Zucker und Salz in die Rührschüssel
und dann verrühren.
Hier auf 70°C.
Und da muss ich auch gleich
aufpassen, denn bei 60°C kommt so diese Schutzfunktion.
Dann wird die Maschine langsamer.
Denn es könnte ja sein, dass ein Kind kommt
und die Maschine auf volle Pulle dreht und dann
einfach heiße Masse rausspritzt.
Und deswegen hat die eine Schutzfunktion.
Das heißt, bei 60°C wird sie langsam
und ihr müsst dann einfach nur bestätigen:
"Hallo, ich bin an der Maschine. Rühr ruhig weiter."
Denn dann kann ich auf Stufe 4 rühren
und in der Zwischenzeit
die Schokolade in der Mikrowelle schmelzen.
Ein bisschen Zeit sparen heute.
Der Tag wird noch lang
und morgen auch.
Und ich habe noch keine Deko.
Und ich denke mir gerade so:
"Was habe ich mir da eigentlich nur angetan?"
Warum guckst du so böse?
>> MURAT: Weil das...
>> SALLY: Aha! Sitzt einfach da in der Ecke
und trägt nichts zur Torte bei.
Hier habe ich jetzt helle und dunkle Streusel
und rühre sie durch.
Denn ich habe ja große und kleine.
Die sollen ja gleichmäßig bräunen.
Hier schon mal jetzt die Platte rauslösen.
[Musik]
Sie ist zwar etwas uneben gebacken,
aber
das wird gleich ausgeglichen.
Ich kann hier schon mal Tonka Wonka noch reingeben.
Tonka und Schokolade sind so
wie Kaffee und Hafermilch.
Unzertrennlich.
Noch fünf Minuten.
Noch fünf Minuten und dann schalte ich die Hitze ab
und lasse es wieder kalt rühren
und kann dann in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal die Butter weich rühren.
[Musik]
>> SALLY & SARAH: When the sun shine, we shine together!
Told you I'll be here forever!
Said I'll always be your friend!
Took an oath, that I'll stick it out till the end!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Eier-Zucker-Masse wieder kalt gerührt,
also handwarm.
Die Schokolade ist geschmolzen.
Und die Butter ist auch schön cremig.
Jetzt füge ich einfach alles zusammen,
das heißt alles hier in die Schüssel.
[Musik]
Und diese Eier-Zucker-Butter-Grundmasse
nehme ich auch gleich für die anderen Torten,
nur kommt da dann keine Schokolade rein.
Da überlege ich mir noch, was reinkommt.
Aber jetzt machen wir erst mal hier die Huttorte.
Und ich kann dann parallel,
immer wenn ich was zum Kühlen habe,
einfach die anderen Cremes rühren.
Und von der Konsistenz her ist sie jetzt so,
schön glänzend und cremig.
Und die Buttercreme, die hält sich auch ein paar Tage.
Ihr könnt die auch im Kühlschrank aufbewahren,
dann wieder rausholen,
auf Zimmertemperatur kommen lassen,
noch mal kurz cremig rühren
und dann einfach noch mal weiter verarbeiten,
wenn ihr möchtet.
Ich fülle sie mir jetzt nur um, weil mir der Topf hier zu groß ist.
Und dann füllen wir jetzt schon mal
die Huttorte.
Ich glaube, das ist auch so die
von der Form her aufwändigste Torte.
Ja.
>> VOLKAN: Ich kann nicht mehr.
>> JOSH: Ja, eindeutig.
>> SALLY: DJ Sally in the house.
Di-di-d!
Dann
kann ich meine eigenen Songs,
meine Stimme schöner machen
und meine eigenen Songs zusammenstellen.
Okay.
Jetzt füllen wir den Hut.
Also wir machen den Hut.
Ich nehme da gerne so eine Antirutschmatte.
Dann kommt da ein Ganaching Board drauf.
Und, wie gesagt, da ja der Hut jetzt nicht so megagroß wird
wie jetzt bei einer allein stehenden Torte
und die Proportionen stimmen sollen,
mache ich den Hut
15 cm im Durchmesser.
Ich habe jetzt hier leider nur 14 cm.
Das heißt,
ich schneide den ersten
mit einem Messer.
Dann stechen wir erst einmal zwei aus mit 14cm.
Und dann
– schwupsdiwups –
schneide ich noch einen zu,
der etwas größer ist.
[Musik]
Und dann nehme ich jetzt einfach kleinere Ausstecher noch.
Ich nasche etwas Kuchenteig.
Schmeckt gut.
>> JOSH: Super.
>> SALLY: Man muss ja auch probieren, was man macht.
>> JOSH: Mmh!
Aber dadurch, dass ich jetzt
nicht heute fertig werde mit der Torte
und sie nicht heute verzehrt wird,
werde ich die Böden noch mit Espresso tränken,
damit sie schön saftig bleiben.
>> ELA: Ich möchte so was ausstechen.
>> SALLY: So was?
Weißt du, ich gebe dir so einen kleinen, pinken Ausstecher.
Dann darfst du hier einen Kreis ausstechen.
>> ELA: Nein!
Eine Blume.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Magst du vielleicht mit mir einen Roboter bauen?
>> SALLY: Einen Roboter?
>> MURAT: Komm, lass uns einen Roboter bauen zu zweit!
Okay?
>> SALLY: Und den Kuchen darfst du mitnehmen.
>> MURAT: Okay, den darfst du mitnehmen.
>> SALLY: Die Zunge!
>> MURAT: Aber dann...
Oh, wow!
Wow!
Komm lass uns einen Roboter bauen!
>> SALLY: Was? Einen Roboter!
>> MURAT: Aus Kartons! Wir haben ganz viele Kartons!
>> SALLY: Oh, cool!
>> MURAT: Okay, viel Spaß!
Danke.
Danke, Ela.
>> ELA: Wir teilen uns den.
>> MURAT: Ja, wir teilen uns das.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Tschüss!
[Musik]
Jetzt tränke ich den Kuchen einfach mit Espresso.
Also, wenn ihr keinen Espresso mögt,
könnt ihr auch Milch nehmen
oder Zuckersirup
oder etwas Rum
oder irgendwas anderes.
Okay.
Und dann kommt jetzt ein bisschen Buttercreme drauf.
Ah, perfekt! Sarah hat die Hafermilch.
Yay!
Brauche ich gleich in meinen Espresso
– in meinen Kaffee.
Dann...
Und für den Crunch habe ich ja hier diese Crunchies.
Die kommen dann hier rein.
Und so werde ich jetzt
die Torte stapeln.
Ich muss auch gleich noch einen Stab holen,
damit die Torte auch schön hält.
Oh, wartet. Ich mache noch mal ein bisschen Creme drauf.
Man kann sie auch zwischendurch mal kühlen.
Denn bei mir ist jetzt die Buttercreme etwas weich.
Aber das ist jetzt nicht schlimm.
>> SAMIRA: Hallo!
>> SALLY: Hallo, Schatzi!
Ich mache eine Harry-Potter-Torte.
>> SAMIRA: Cool!
>> SALLY: Hast du Harry Potter schon mal gesehen?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Echt?
Also den Anfang würde ich schon so gerade machen
und dann nach oben...
Das machen wir aber dann mit Marshmallow-Rice-Crispie.
>> SAMIRA: Weil das wird dann ein bisschen schwierig
mit dem Biegen.
Nicht, dass sie dann einstürzt.
>> SALLY: Und umfällt, nicht?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
So.
>> SALLY: So. Das kommt jetzt in den Kühlschrank.
>> SAMIRA: Eh oh, eh oh.
>> SALLY: Eh oh.
>> SAMIRA: Das weiß ich nur ganz alleine.
>> SALLY & SAMIRA: Eh oh.
>> SAMIRA: Das ist alles nur geklaut und gestohlen...
>> SALLY: So. Ich nehme jetzt hier einen Stab,
ein Rundholz, 0,5 mm.
Und den schneide ich jetzt 25 cm lang zu.
Das ist hier.
Denn
– kannst du das festhalten, Schatz?
Denn der Hut wird ja nach oben hin gebogen.
>> SAMIRA: Nicht nachmachen!
>> SALLY: Warum?
>> SAMIRA: Weil es gefährlich ist.
>> SALLY: Guck mal. Ich ritze das
– Achtung, drehen.
Ich ritze das so an und dann breche ich es durch.
Ta-daa!
Ja.
Und der kommt jetzt hier rein.
Ta-da-da-daa!
Und jetzt staple ich einfach noch so lange,
wie ich eben auch Creme und Tortenböden habe.
[Musik]
Und den Rest mache ich aus Marshmallow.
Und das kommt jetzt hier aber erst mal in den Kühlschrank.
Oder vielleicht sogar in die Gefrierkühltruhe.
Da geht es ein bisschen schneller.
Da wird er schneller fest.
Ah, guckt einmal. Die Zwischenlücken hier,
die kann ich noch kurz ausfüllen
und dann in den Kühlschrank stellen.
Denn dann ist der hier schon mal fest, der Kuchen.
Ich könnte so eine Umfrage starten:
"Wer will am Freitag spontan
mit einer Harry-Potter-Torte heiraten?
Wer will sie als Hochzeitstorte?"
>> SAMIRA: Ich!
>> SALLY: Es gibt...
>> SAMIRA: Dafür würde ich nicht heiraten,
>> SALLY: Entschuldigung?!
>> SAMIRA: aber egal.
>> JOSH: Da muss ich mal fragen.
Wen heiratest du denn schon?
>> SAMIRA: Nein, ich will ja nicht heiraten.
Ich will ja nur die Torte haben.
>> JOSH: Gibt es schon jemand?
>> SALLY: Papa ist auch mein bester Freund.
Sodele.
Die kommt jetzt in die Gefrierkühltruhe.
Machst du die mir auf?
Wenn sie noch reinpasst von der Höhe.
[Musik]
Aber gerade so.
Hm.
Weiter geht es mit der zweiten Torte,
also zweites Stockwerk.
Da habe ich ja schon die beiden Böden vorgebacken,
das Crumble.
Die Apfelmasse ist im Kühlschrank.
Und da mache ich jetzt auch die Buttercreme.
Da nehme ich einfach die gleiche Menge,
also sechs Eier,
200 Gramm Zucker,
etwas Salz,
450 Gramm weiche Butter
und für das Aroma einfach etwas Karamell
und ein bisschen Zitronenabrieb.
Und die Zubereitung ist hier die gleiche
wie bei der Schokocreme.
Das heißt, die Eier werden mit dem Zucker und dem Salz
bei 70°C etwa zehn Minuten erwärmt
und gleichzeitig schaumig gerührt.
Danach nehmt ihr die Hitze weg
und die Eiermasse wird dann kalt gerührt.
Die Butter kann dann in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal cremig gerührt werden.
Und dann gebe ich nur noch Karamell und Zitrone dazu
und verrühre alles zusammen.
So.
Solange die Creme noch rührt,
kann ich jetzt hier schon mal die Tortenböden rauslösen.
Und ich rühre parallel auch schon die dritte Buttercreme.
Also es geht hier heiß zu.
Denn wir wollen vorankommen.
Eins, zwei. Eins, zwei.
[Musik]
Ich finde es bei Torten immer megawichtig,
dass die Tortenböden schön dünn sind.
Denn dann schmeckt die Torte einfach besser,
wie wenn man einfach so einen dicken
Kuchen
– wie wenn man so eine dicke Schicht Kuchen hat.
Also immer schön Füllung dazwischen.
Dann schmeckt es auch ein bisschen abwechslungsreicher.
Man hat zwar ein bisschen mehr Arbeit damit,
aber es lohnt sich.
So. Durchgeschnitten sind sie.
Jetzt kann ich noch schnell die Buttercreme zusammenfügen
und dann die Torte füllen.
[Musik]
In diese Buttercreme gebe ich jetzt,
wie gesagt, etwas Karamell.
Was ihr hier auch ganz gut nehmen könnt,
sind diese Karamellbonbons.
Die könnt ihr einschmelzen,
mit etwas Sahne zum Beispiel,
und dann dazu geben.
Eine Prise Zitronenabrieb.
Da war meine Stimme gerade zu hoch, nicht?
Abrieb.
Egal.
Und hier jetzt die Butter rein.
Ja, es ist alles Butter.
>> SARAH: O Gott!
>> SALLY: Mein Gott!
Sarah schreit schon: "O Gott!"
Ja, wir essen ja die Torte nicht alleine!
Marcel isst auch mit.
Und Siamak.
Nur Dennis und Volkan nicht.
Denn sie ist nicht vegan.
[Musik]
Ich sage es euch, das ist wirklich kräfteraubend.
Sie ist eingefroren.
Gut, es gibt Schlimmeres.
Schlimmer wäre es, wenn die Torte nicht fest wird.
Jetzt nehme ich ein 25-cm-Ganaching Board.
Da kommt der erste Boden drauf.
Manchmal ziehen sich Teige nach dem Backen zusammen.
Deswegen ist es dann immer gut,
wenn ihr die gleiche Größe einstellt wie das Ganaching Board.
Dieser Mandelrührkuchen,
der zieht sich allerdings fast nie zusammen.
Also da könnt ihr gerne den Tortenring 5 mm kleiner einstellen,
– ich zeige euch auch später warum –
damit wir das Ganaching Board zum Füllen benutzen können.
Okay.
Und jetzt wird das Ganze gefüllt
mit der Karamell-Zitronen-Creme.
Dann die Apfelfüllung.
[Musik]
Hier fülle ich jetzt auch noch etwas Creme ein,
so ungefähr 300 Gramm.
Denn damit kann ich jetzt eine Umrandung hier draufspritzen.
[Musik]
Die Mitte noch ein bisschen auffüllen.
Dann kommen hier jetzt noch die Crumble drauf.
[Musik]
Und dann der nächste Boden.
Und so fülle ich jetzt die ganze Torte
und schließe dann mit einem schönen glatten Boden ab.
Und wenn ihr das Gefühl habt, die Torte ist zu weich,
stellt sie einfach kurz ins Gefrierfach oder in den Kühlschrank
und füllt dann eben erst weiter.
[Musik]
So. Letzte Schicht.
Natürlich alles wieder
perfekt abgemessen.
Hallo!
Kommt ruhig her.
>> BESUCHER: Kann ich?
>> SALLY: Ja, natürlich.
>> BESUCHER: Ich will doch mal wieder
den Traum meiner schlaflosen Nächte sehen.
Grüße dich!
Oh, ich freue mich!
>> SALLY: Hallo!
>> BESUCHERIN: Hallo!
>> SALLY: Wer aber ins Bild kommt,
muss auch einmal winken.
>> BESUCHER: Baumkuchen?
>> SALLY: Harry-Potter-Torte.
>> BESUCHER: Harry-Potter-Torte? Okay.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Hallo!
>> BESUCHERIN: Hallo!
>> SALLY: So. Die letzten Streuselchen.
O Gott im Himmel!
Das ist jetzt schon...
Also ich überlege jetzt schon, wer
– ich nehme jetzt noch die Streusel.
Alles rein.
Alle Brösel.
Ich überlege jetzt schon, wer die Torte alles essen soll.
Und jetzt, wie gesagt, der Boden als Abschluss.
Und ich finde es hier echt schön,
dass es eine hohe Torte ist.
Denn dann kann ich den Rand auch schön dekorieren.
Einmal Kontrolle.
Ja.
Und dann lege ich hier
den Tortenretter drauf
und eine Tortenwaage.
Perfekt!
Und die Torte darf jetzt über Nacht in den Kühlschrank
und darf auskühlen und fest werden.
Ich werde sie jetzt nur noch
– damit sie einfach am Rand
auch schon mal schön gerade wird.
Also ich könnte sie auch so in den Kühlschrank packen,
aber einpacken,
damit es einfach nicht nach Kühlschrank riecht.
Ich mache es jetzt aber so:
Ich lege einen Tortenring außenrum
und, damit ich den wieder ganz einfach wegbekomme
ohne jetzt großartig mit dem Tortenmesser,
mache ich hier noch Wachspapier außenrum.
Backpapier geht aber auch.
Und so habe ich sie zum einen vor Gerüchen geschützt
und zum anderen wird sie schön stabil
und eben auch schon mal gerade.
Und hier oben schlage ich es dann ein.
Ich glaube, ich muss den extra hohen Tortenring nehmen.
Ja.
Und ich drücke den jetzt tatsächlich ein bisschen zusammen,
dass er etwas kleiner ist als 25 cm.
So kann ich ihn morgen dann nämlich,
wenn er gut durchgekühlt ist,
schön gerade an den Seiten bestreichen.
Ich decke es jetzt hier auch noch ab.
Und dann ist er schön luftdicht verschlossen.
Hu! Torte zwei ist gefüllt.
Jetzt kommt Torte drei.
O Gott!
[Musik]
Das gleiche Spiel jetzt auch bei der 9-3/4-Torte.
Die Zimtböden einfach durchschneiden.
Und da habe ich ja jetzt auch schon die Buttercreme gerührt.
Den ersten Boden lege ich hier auch schon mal drauf.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich hier auch die Buttercreme
fertigstellen zuerst einmal.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt hier die weiche Butter,
die Eiermasse
und ich nehme jetzt noch mal Zimt.
Das soll wirklich eine schöne Zimt-Kirsch-Torte werden.
Jetzt brauche ich erst mal einen Teigschaber.
Ich habe jetzt auch voll viel in der Spülmaschine schon parallel.
Und hier ist echt immer wichtig,
dass diese Eiermasse schön abgekühlt wird,
dass die wieder kalt gerührt wird.
Ansonsten schmilzt nämlich die Butter
und dann habt ihr keine Buttercreme,
sondern so eine flüssige Creme.
Wenn es doch mal passiert,
einfach kurz in den Kühlschrank geben
und dann eben noch mal schön verrühren.
[Musik]
Und ihr seht auch, die wird erst mal noch mal flüssiger.
Aber ihr müsst jetzt einfach rühren,
die ganze Zeit rühren.
Das könnt ihr auch mit der Küchenmaschine machen.
Sie wird dann wieder schön homogen.
Die Mädels helfen mir hier schon mit dem Geschirr.
Die Jungs auch, der Josh auch.
O Gott!
So. Und hier mache ich es jetzt so,
dass ich zuerst die Böden mit der Kirschmasse bestreiche
und die Torte dann mit der Zimtcreme befülle.
[Musik]
Düt!
Dütt! Dütt! Dütt! Düt!
Düt! Dütt! Dütt!
>> SARAH: Eingeparkt.
>> SALLY: Parkhilfe.
>> SARAH: Dütt, dütt, dütt, dütt, dütt, düt!
>> SALLY: Okay.
Düt!
>> JOSH: Ein bisschen irre.
>> SARAH: Ja!
>> SALLY: Sie wird irre.
>> SARAH: Man merkt bei ihr die Uhrzeit langsam.
>> SALLY: Was?
Was? Ihr merkt bei mir die Uhrzeit?
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Perfekt!
Und jetzt hier den Rand noch schön machen.
Hier kommt jetzt auch etwas Papier drumherum,
ein Tortenring, ein Deckel drauf.
Und dann kommt die Torte in den Kühlschrank.
[Musik]
Ich muss euch eins sagen.
Die Marshmallow-Spitze mache ich heute nicht mehr.
Das machen wir morgen.
Wir fangen morgen damit an.
Jetzt wird aufgeräumt!
Morgen geht es weiter!
Oh!
Kann die jemand tragen?
Ich kann nicht mehr.
Tschüss!
Ja.
Warte mal. Die Menge ist für die weiße Schokolade.
Right?
Und das für die kleine.
>> AYLIN: Genau. Das sind jetzt noch 800 ml.
>> SALLY: Für da noch dazu?
>> AYLIN: Genau.
>> SALLY: Okay.
I under-
>> AYLIN: Das ist weg hier.
>> SALLY: stand!
Okay.
>> SARAH: Genug.
>> SALLY: Also
pst!
>> JOSH & SARAH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Gut.
Ich mache jetzt eine Ganache.
Guten Morgen! Heute ist der nächste Tag.
Und zwar mache ich einmal eine weiße Ganache
und eine Vollmilch-Ganache.
Und damit werden dann die Torten später glatt gestrichen.
Ihr könnt auch mehr Buttercreme machen.
Aber die Ganache wird immer ein bisschen fester
und dann ist das Arbeiten einfacher,
weil Ganache nicht so schnell schmilzt wie Buttercreme.
Ihr macht solang
Frühstückswraps?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Yay!
Okay.
Sehr gut!
Und für die Ganache reibt ihr einfach die Schokolade fein
oder ihr hackt sie fein,
kocht Sahne auf
und dann rührt ihr alles miteinander.
Ja,
kannst du ruhig auch.
Ja.
Aylin?
>> AYLIN: Ja.
>> SALLY: Wir üben jetzt die Aussprache.
>> AYLIN: Okay.
>> SALLY: Sag. Sag: Wie heißt das?
>> AYLIN: Pasabahce.
>> SALLY: Nein. Wir üben jetzt alle zusammen.
Paşabahçe.
>> SARAH & JOSH & AYLIN: Paşabahçe.
>> SALLY: Paşabahçe.
>> SALLY: Sehr gut!
>> AYLIN: Was machen wir jetzt?
>> JOSH: Weitermachen.
>> SALLY: Sehr, sehr gut!
Ja.
Und normalerweise
reibe ich die Schokolade auch mal so per Hand.
Aber jetzt habe ich wirklich sehr viel Schokolade.
Und ich mache jetzt eine große Menge,
weil ich noch nicht weiß,
wie viel Ganache ich brauchen werde.
Aber
ich kann sie ja einfrieren, wenn ich sie nicht komplett brauche,
und dann habe ich für das nächste Mal schon Ganache fertig.
Das ist eigentlich übrigens immer so, nicht?
Wir machen immer was nebenher, was anderes.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Entweder Frühstück oder Mittag.
>> JOSH: Das hat was von Multitasking.
>> SALLY: Ja, immer Multitasking.
Also, wenn ihr öfter Einblick hinter die Kulissen haben wollt,
dann sagt einfach Bescheid.
Wir machen auch gleich Hefeteig.
Denn heute Mittag gibt es Pizza.
>> JOSH: Nice!
>> SALLY: Habe ich euch das noch gar nicht gesagt?
>> SARAH: Voll die Überraschung!
>> SALLY: Wuh!
>> JOSH:Das ging an uns vorbei irgendwie.
>> SALLY: Und jeder kann sie sich belegen.
Oh, wie bei so einem Kindergeburtstag!
>> SARAH: Das ist echt cool!
Wir machen eine Belegparty.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Also ich werde jetzt hier die Sahne
einmal hier aufkochen für die große Menge.
Denn so eine große Rührschüssel habe ich nicht.
Und dann habe ich noch die andere Sahne
für die dunkle Ganache, für die Vollmilch-Ganache.
Und wie heißt das?
>> SARAH: Paşabahçe.
>> SALLY: Aferin!
Super, Sarah!
>> SARAH: Angehende Türkin.
>> SALLY: Ja, du bist voll schon eingetürkt.
[Musik]
So. Die Sahne ist gekocht.
Schaffe ich es ohne Kleckern?
[Musik]
Und jetzt rühre ich sie hier weiter,
natürlich ohne Hitze.
Denn die Hitze der Sahne reicht schon aus.
Und sobald diese Ganache hier jetzt auch verrührt ist
und schön geschmeidig ist,
decke ich sie ab.
Ich fülle sie aber in drei Portionen ab.
Ja.
Dann kühlt sie nämlich schneller ab.
Ich lasse sie bei Raumtemperatur
oder ganz, ganz kurz im Kühlschrank fest werden,
bis sie streichfähig ist,
und mache jetzt direkt mit dem Hut weiter.
Da kommt nämlich Marshmallow-Rice-Crispie drauf.
Ja.
[Musik]
Ich hoffe, wir brauchen nicht die ganze Ganache.
Das wäre schon heftig.
[Musik]
Jetzt geht es mit der Huttorte weiter.
Ich habe hier ein Bild
für mich, was ich hierher stelle.
Und da oben möchte ich jetzt diese Spitze formen.
Das heißt, ich brauche jetzt Marshmallows und Rice Crispies.
Die habe ich jetzt eins zu eins,
das heißt 200 Gramm Marshmallows,
200 Gramm Rice Crispies
und 20 Gramm Butter.
Und die Marshmallows werden jetzt
in der Mikrowelle geschmolzen
oder in einer Pfanne.
Aber Mikrowelle ist hier wirklich viel, viel einfacher.
[Musik]
Da sind sie jetzt, die weichen Marshmallows.
Sie sehen nicht heiß aus,
aber glaubt es mir, sie sind superheiß.
Da kommt jetzt die Butter rein.
Die schmilzt darin.
Also nicht mit den Fingern rein!
Das ist wirklich heiße Zuckermasse.
Und hier jetzt die Schoko Crispies rein.
Und das ist wirklich zum einen superlecker
und zum anderen kann man es wirklich benutzen,
um alles Mögliche zu formen.
Und jetzt fette ich meine Hände.
Jetzt dürfte es auch nicht mehr so heiß sein.
Das heißt, ihr könnt sie jetzt nehmen
und die Masse dann einfach schön kneten.
>> SARAH: Hui!
>> SALLY: Aber es ist wirklich superlecker!
Da gibt es sogar in Amerika einen Müsliriegel
oder halt so einen Schokoriegel.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier diese Masse
und meine Vorlage, den Hut.
Ich habe mir einfach ein Bild aus dem Film
so aus dem Internet genommen.
Ich habe extra ein bisschen mehr gemacht,
damit wir was zum Naschen haben!
Und die kann man jetzt so ein bisschen zusammendrücken.
So wird sie kompakter.
[Musik]
Und ich habe gesehen, dass die Torte
unten doch noch ein bisschen breiter ist.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt hier auch einfach diese restlichen
Stränge nehmen
und unten noch drankleben.
Gerade hier so ein bisschen.
Ich habe jetzt hier noch mal
Buttercreme unten an den Rand gestrichen,
– nee, ist okay, Sarah, mach ruhig Bilder, das passt –
damit diese Wurst hier hält.
Wir wollten ja ein bisschen Backstage zeigen,
wie wir alles machen.
Das machen wir immer,
Fotos, Videos, alles parallel.
Und ich liebe diesen Hut,
weil der einfach so keine Form hat.
Also da könnt ihr wirklich nichts falsch machen.
Ich gucke jetzt noch mal.
Die Augen müssten ungefähr hierhin.
Ja, der Hut hat Augen.
Hier machen wir noch so eine Mininase.
Hier
so eine Erhöhung für die Nase.
Da-da-da-da-daa!
Oh, wisst ihr was ich als Nächstes machen muss?
Diesen sprechenden Baum von Efteling,
dieser Märchenbaum.
Hm.
Ja.
Den mache ich.
Und jetzt hier unten der Mund.
Mh, man darf nicht mit vollem Mund reden.
Kannst du auch die Krümel
aus meinen Zähnen rausretuschieren?
>> SARAH: Ja.
Warum? Hängt da ein Marshmallow?
>> SALLY: Guckt mal. Und hier...
>> JOSH: Achtung! Deine Spitze fällt ab.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Ja, ich muss die in Ding packen
– in Folie einpacken.
Die muss erst mal fest werden.
Und da unten noch so der Mund.
So nur die Grundstruktur.
Den Rest mache ich dann
mit Ganache und Kuchenbröseln und so weiter.
[Musik]
>> SIAMAK: Danke schön.
>> SALLY: Bitte.
Ein Leckerli.
Wir haben das voll oft in der alten Wohnung gemacht, gell?
Das war so unser Highlight.
>> SIAMAK: Lecker!
>> SALLY: Lecker, lecker, lecker!
Kennst du das?
>> SIAMAK: Mh?
>> SALLY: Das Video mit dem "Lecker, lecker, lecker!"
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: O Gott.
Wieso kennt das jeder?
>> SIAMAK: Fische füttern?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SIAMAK: Ja, ja.
>> SARAH: Mmh! Lecker, lecker, lecker!
>> SALLY: Der Hut erinnert mich an irgendjemanden,
der auch so Augenbrauen hat.
>> SARAH: Sag mal.
>> SALLY: Aber an wen?
Niemand von hier.
Kurz alle abgecheckt.
Und wenn das hier oben nicht hält, könnt ihr
einfach ein bisschen Frischhaltefolie nehmen
und das drumrumwickeln.
Aber jetzt
so langsam hält es eigentlich.
Aber ich knicke sie noch ein bisschen ab.
So passt es.
Der Rest ist für uns.
Ich mache uns einen Riegel.
Nee, ich mache uns Kugeln.
Jetzt kommt die Torte in den Kühlschrank
und wird dann gleich mit der Ganache überzogen.
Die sollte streichfähig sein.
Zwei,
drei,
vier.
Wollt ihr?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Frühstück.
>> JOSH: Nachtisch.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> SARAH: Ich frühstücke heute.
>> SALLY: Okay. Dann nehmt euch.
Mmh!
>> SIAMAK: Ja, ich nehme noch mal.
So ist jetzt hier gerade der Zwischenstand:
Der Hut hat schon seine Strukturen.
Die beiden sind gefüllt
und richtig gut über Nacht durchgekühlt.
Und die Ganache, die kühlt jetzt gerade noch ein bisschen.
Aber jetzt kann ich im Prinzip diese zwei Torten
schon mal mit Ganache überziehen.
Und da mache ich es jetzt einfach so:
Ich mache eine erste Schicht drauf,
die hier diese Krümel bindet,
diese Lücken ausfüllt,
stelle sie dann in den Kühlschrank
und danach streiche ich sie noch mal richtig glatt.
Also jetzt Step by Step.
Die kommt in den Kühlschrank.
Die kommt auch in den Kühlschrank.
Mit der kleinen lege ich los.
Und so benutze ich das Ganaching Board,
um die Torte am Rand hier richtig schön glatt zu bekommen.
Und das Ganze wirklich in ganz wenigen Schritten.
Also das bekommt wirklich jeder hin.
Ich werde jetzt aber, wie gesagt,
zuerst einmal hier den Rand mit Ganache bestreichen,
damit hier diese Krümel einfach nicht mehr abfallen.
Und dafür nehme ich jetzt die Ganache,
die noch nicht ganz so fest ist.
Noch nicht streichfähig lässt sie sich nämlich besser verteilen.
[Musik]
Aber für die nächste Schicht, für die glatte Schicht
muss die Ganache auf jeden Fall streichfähig sein.
Sonst müht ihr euch da sehr ab.
Und dann kommt da die nächste Schicht drauf.
Sehr schön!
Ab in den Kühlschrank!
>> MURAT: Hey!
Ich war gerade im Zauberstabladen
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> MURAT: und zwar im Ollivanders.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Und da habe ich dir einen Zauberstab geholt.
Ja, krass, oder?
>> SALLY: Harry Potter?
>> MURAT: Nein.
Und zwar ist der vom Dumbledore.
>> SALLY: Warum nicht Harry?
>> MURAT: Weil der im Angebot war.
Der hat nur die Hälfte gekostet.
So.
Ollivanders heißt der Laden.
Da könnt ihr die Zauberstäbe holen.
Kennt jemand noch Lilo Wanders?
Kennt das...
Nee, ist nicht wichtig.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Vielleicht geht es damit schneller.
>> MURAT: Wenn es damit schneller geht,
das wäre echt der Wahnsinn, oder?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Also Ollivanders.
Lilo Wanders.
>> SALLY: Ich probiere ihn aus.
Partis Temporus!
Hat nicht geklappt.
Warte.
Ein Explosionsspruch!
Bombarda Maxima!
Es hat geklappt!
Mal gucken, was ich mir damit noch so alles wünschen kann.
So.
Die glatte Torte kommt jetzt in den Kühlschrank.
Da darf sie noch mal ein bisschen durchkühlen.
Und ich mache noch die anderen Torten schön glatt.
Und dann geht es gleich weiter.
Oh, der Hut. Der Hut!
Kannst du auch den Hut machen?
Nee, dann kann ich euch ja nicht zeigen, wie es funktioniert.
Okay, den Hut machen wir selber.
Den lassen wir nicht zaubern.
Hier ist jetzt die mittlere Torte,
also die Harry-Potter-Torte,
die Betonoptik-Apple-Crumble-Torte.
So. Jetzt habe ich es.
Und jetzt wird sie glatt gestrichen.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach ein zweites Ganaching Board.
Und das hat ja 25 cm im Durchmesser.
Und da jetzt einfach darauf achten,
dass es schön im rechten Winkel hier aufliegt,
also nicht zu weit rüber.
Und jetzt werden diese Lücken hier
einfach mit der übrigen Ganache aufgefüllt.
Und so wird der Rand schön glatt.
[Musik]
Ruhig auch großzügiger auftragen.
Und wenn ihr sie dann großzügig aufgetragen habt,
nehmt ihr jetzt diese große Teigkarte,
setzt sie hier an
und zieht den Rest weg.
[Musik]
Und ich kühle die Torte jetzt,
damit die Ganache hier fest wird.
Dann kann ich hier noch mal die Lücken ausfüllen
und noch mal einmal schön glatt abziehen.
O Gott!
Die wird immer schwerer.
Puh!
[Musik]
Ist das der?
>> SARAH: Ich gucke gerade.
Nee, guck!
>> SALLY: Sarah behauptet,
>> SARAH: Guck!
>> SALLY: das wäre nicht der Dumbledore...
>> SARAH: Das ist auch nicht der Dumbledore Zauberstab.
Guck dir den an.
So sieht der Dumbledore...
>> SALLY: Ja, du hast recht.
>> SARAH: Das ist so was von falsch!
Siamak, gell?
Wie heißt der Zauberstab von Dumbledore?
>> SIAMAK: Nimbus 2000.
>> SALLY: Nimbus 2000.
>> SIAMAK: Oder?
>> SARAH: Das ist der Besen von Harry.
>> SIAMAK: Oh! Das kann ich mir aber merken.
Oder 200?
>> SALLY & SARAH: 2000.
>> SALLY: Stimmt, Nimbus 2000, der Besen.
>> SARAH: Das ist der Besen.
Und der Elderstab ist das nicht.
Der Dumbledore hat den Elderstab.
>> SALLY: Die haben dich veräppelt, Murat.
Kannst du zurückgeben.
>> MURAT: Warum? Mir ist das egal.
>> SALLY: Ja, dir ist es egal.
>> SARAH: Guck mal. Da gibt es zweierlei.
>> SALLY: Der Magic Stick ist der falsche.
>> SARAH: Ich kann es mit dem Zauberstab...
>> MURAT: Der Magic Stick ist vom 50 Cent.
>> SALLY: Was?
50 Cent?
>> MURAT: Kennst du das nicht? I've got the magic stick.
>> SARAH: I'll take you to the candy shop.
>> SALLY: I'll take you to the candy shop
and let you
>> SARAH: Lick my lollipop.
>> SALLY: lick the lollipop.
>> MURAT: This ist the magic stick.
>> SALLY: Als Kind habe ich das einfach nie verstanden.
Und meine Schwester wollte immer nie,
dass ich das Lied singe.
>> SARAH: Hat sie es verstanden?
>> SALLY: Ja, sie ist 13 Jahre älter.
>> SARAH: Ach so.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Man hört immer das raus, was man hören will.
>> SARAH: Leck den Zauberstab alleine.
>> SALLY: Ja?
Ich gebe ihn zurück.
Der Schwabentrick.
Habe ich mir beim Murat abgeguckt.
Guckt mal. Ich zeige euch mal hier den Unterschied.
Und zwar habe ich hier die Ganache in zwei Behälter abgefüllt.
Hier ist sie noch zu flüssig
und hier ist sie schon fast zu fest.
Aber ich benutze jetzt beide.
Denn an manchen Stellen brauche ich jetzt hier diese festere
und ihr könnt da auch mit der Palette
einfach so ein bisschen reinrühren
und dann wird die ja schon geschmeidig, schön streichfest.
Und die etwas flüssigere
brauche ich dann zum richtigen Glätten.
Also es passt so schon ganz gut.
Und wenn sie euch mal wirklich zu fest ist,
kurz in die Mikrowelle oder über ein Wasserbad
und dann könnt ihr sie benutzen.
Und Reste wirklich einfach immer nur einfrieren
und wieder auftauen.
Das klappt wunderbar.
Und das liegt jetzt wirklich einfach nur daran:
Die war nicht im Kühlschrank.
Die war im Kühlschrank.
Und die kann man so geschmeidig rühren.
Und die Temperatur macht eben auch
diesen Farbunterschied.
Also es war ein und dieselbe Ganache.
Okay.
Mit der Ganache
– und daher habe ich sie jetzt auch gemacht –
kann ich jetzt hier die Torte glätten.
Beziehungsweise die wird ja eh nicht ganz glatt.
>> MURAT: Halt! Ich brauche ein Foto für Instagram.
Danke.
>> SALLY: Bitte.
Die wird jetzt eh nicht ganz glatt,
sondern ich fülle jetzt hier im Prinzip alles aus
und der Hut, der hat ja schon ein bisschen
eine schöne Struktur.
Und durch diese Falten entsteht ja auch das Gesicht.
Und das probiere ich jetzt hier mit der Palette
und der Ganache.
[Musik]
Puh!
Jetzt bekommt das Gesicht noch mehr Struktur.
Das heißt, ihr nehmt jetzt diese Ganache
– ich habe jetzt auch diese spitze Palette.
Die ist vorne so angespitzt
wie eine Spitze.
Und damit könnt ihr wirklich
diese schönen Geschichtszüge machen.
Gesichtszüge am Hut.
[Musik]
Hier setze ich jetzt gerade noch die Kuchenreste dran,
einfach überall da, wo ich denke,
da passt noch so ein Gesichtszug hin.
Denn gerade hier jetzt zum Beispiel war es mir zu wenig.
Dann nehme ich einfach den Kuchenrest
und noch etwas Buttercreme.
Die ist nämlich weicher als Ganache.
Ups!
Und damit lässt es sich nämlich besser ankleben.
Wie so eine Art Cake-Pops-Masse
wird das dann so ein bisschen zerbröselt, vermischt.
Und guckt mal. Dann hält das schön.
Ansonsten, wenn ihr sagt, ihr möchtet das einfacher machen,
könnt ihr auch Marzipan nehmen
und einfach Marzipanstränge hinmachen.
Geht wirklich viel einfacher.
Denn ihr müsst es einfach nur modellieren und ankleben.
Oder Modellierschokolade.
Aber so habe ich einfach eine leckere Masse drunter
und nicht einfach so eine Schicht Marzipan.
[Musik]
Die Torte ist jetzt schön fest.
Sie ist noch nicht im Wasser, also noch nicht ausgeglichen,
aber das passt.
Ich nehme jetzt hier das Ganaching Board weg
Und das Ganaching Board, das besteht aus Polycarbonat,
ist lebensmittelecht
und es ist ein wirklich bruchsicheres Material.
[Musik]
Hier kommt jetzt eine Ganache-Schicht drauf zum Glätten.
Jetzt sind alle Torten glatt gestrichen.
Die
größte Arbeit ist getan, wollte ich gerade sagen.
Aber das stimmt nicht.
Die Deko kommt ja noch.
Aber die Grundbausteine sind schon mal gesetzt.
Und jetzt habe ich mir überlegt,
dass ich die Torte Gleis 9 3/4 mit Grau überziehe
und dann Backsteine drauf mache.
Und die mittlere Torte überziehe ich grau
und die wird so eine Betonoptik haben.
Und jetzt mache ich aber erst mal die große Torte,
also die 9 3/4.
Hier habe ich jetzt weißen Fondant.
Das ist eine Zuckerüberzugsmasse.
Und den kann ich jetzt mit schwarzem Fondant vermischen.
Ich probiere jetzt erst mal ein kleines Stückchen Schwarz,
damit ich ein helles Grau erhalte.
[Musik]
Ah!
Ich wollte heute noch zum Sport,
aber das spare ich mir heute.
Ich glaube, ich kann da jetzt noch so ein paar
Kniebeugen machen und dann habe ich mein Workout durch.
Und wenn ihr möchtet,
könnt ihr die Hände mit etwas Kokosfett
oder Kokosöl eben einfetten.
[Musik]
Jetzt brauche ich erst mal nur einen Teil
für die große Torte.
Und den Fondant wirklich immer schön lange durchkneten,
damit er geschmeidig ist.
Durch die Handwärme wird er nämlich schön warm.
Und wenn er doch mal zu kalt ist,
einfach kurz in die Mikrowelle stellen.
Nicht zu lange, damit er nicht trocknet.
So. Das können wir kurz wegpacken.
Und jetzt rolle ich den einfach auf Bäckerstärke aus.
Bäckerstärke ist Kartoffelstärke und die klumpt nicht.
Also da jetzt wirklich keine Speisestärke benutzen.
Denn da bleiben dann Rückstände
und bei der Bäckerstärke bleiben keine.
Und bei Puderzucker kann es passieren,
dass der Fondant anfängt zu kleben.
Und so habt ihr die Probleme einfach nicht.
Jetzt rolle ich das schön dünn aus.
Bei der Gleis-9-3/4-Torte wirklich extrem dünn,
denn da kommt ja dann noch eine Schicht Fondant drauf
durch die Backsteine.
Und dann habt ihr nicht so eine allzu dicke Schicht.
Und wenn ihr mal Luftbläschen habt so wie hier,
könnt ihr die aufstechen,
vorsichtig die Luft rausstreichen
und dann einfach drüberrollen.
[Musik]
Jetzt besprühe ich die Torte mit etwas Backtrennspray,
damit der Fondant schön haftet.
Ansonsten ist ja nämlich die Ganache jetzt einfach trocken
und der Fondant würde nicht haften.
[Musik]
Und jetzt hier die Fondantdecke entweder aufrollen
oder auf den Armen hochnehmen
und dann über die Torte legen.
[Musik]
Dann glätte ich immer erst mal die Oberfläche,
damit die Luft hier an den Seiten entweichen kann.
Hier ist jetzt noch eine Luftblase,
aber das ist nicht schlimm.
Denn das ist sowieso das unterste Stockwerk.
Und jetzt hier eine Hand,
die drückt oder glättet hier den Fondant
und die andere zieht den hier weg.
Und so kann man eben diese Falten einfach wegstreichen.
Und ihr seht schon, der ist auch gar nicht so rissig.
Ich habe den wirklich ganz lange durchgeknetet.
Und der hier ist mit Sheabutter.
Das heißt, der ist allgemein einfach nicht so rissig.
Und dann kann man da wirklich schön lange modellieren,
ohne dass an der Seite was einreißt.
[Musik]
Die Reste schneide ich jetzt hier weg
und kann sie dann auch wieder zusammenkneten
und für die andere Torte benutzen.
Und luftdicht verpackt könnt ihr Fondant
übrigens mehrere Wochen aufbewahren.
Da passiert nichts.
Und jetzt nehme ich meine zwei Glätter,
glätte erst mal die Oberfläche.
Ich weiß, worauf ihr wartet.
Doktor,
kann ich?
Okay, 300 Volt.
Ich habe zu viel Grey’s Anatomy geguckt.
>> SARAH: Im Winter vor allem.
>> SALLY: Wahrscheinlich habe ich jetzt
den Patienten getötet.
[Musik]
Ich meine, die müsste jetzt eh nicht so perfekt sein.
Da kommen eh die Backsteine außenrum.
Aber ich habe gerne, dass meine Torten perfekt sind.
Okay.
Dann kann die Torte jetzt in den Kühlschrank.
Und weil ich immer gefragt werde,
wie lange sich Fondanttorten halten:
Es kommt zum einen natürlich auf die Füllung an.
Ich habe jetzt hier eine Füllung mit Kirschen und Buttercreme.
Das hält sich schon vier bis fünf Tage.
Und sobald ihr diese Fondantschicht drauf habt,
ist es einfach so wie
so eine Art Decke und Ummantelung,
die einfach die Torte vor der Außenwelt schützt.
Dadurch bleibt sie einfach ein bisschen haltbar
und sie trocknet eben nicht aus.
Wenn ich jetzt aber eine Quark-Sahne-Füllung habe,
dann würde ich die schon innerhalb von zwei Tagen essen.
Aber die hier, die könnte ich jetzt schon
locker so zwei, drei Tage noch aufbewahren.
Da passiert nichts.
Im Kühlschrank natürlich.
Also es kommt wirklich immer
so ein bisschen auf die Füllung an.
Eine Sachertorte zum Beispiel,
die könnt ihr dann sieben Tage aufbewahren,
so eine ganze Woche.
Passiert nichts.
Ihr dürft jetzt nur nicht folgenden Fehler machen.
Also die Torte kommt so in den Kühlschrank
ohne Abdeckung,
da ja jetzt praktisch der Fondant die Abdeckung ist.
Und da jetzt wirklich keine Schüssel mehr außenrum machen.
Ansonsten schwitzt der Fondant
und dann geht die Torte schon kaputt,
also optisch.
Sodele.
Ach! Ich kann die bald nicht mehr tragen.
So.
Da ist noch ein Luftbläschen.
Jetzt ist es weg.
[Musik]
Bei dieser Torte habe ich jetzt den Fondant ausgerollt
und etwa zehn Minuten liegen lassen, damit er antrocknet.
Denn ich möchte jetzt eine Betonoptik
so wie hier an meiner Wand.
Und das ist hier auch
– ich meine, es ist nicht rissig,
sondern das sind eher Luftlöcher, die entstehen,
wenn man eben diese Folie an die Wand drückt.
Aber ich will es so ein bisschen rissig haben,
ein paar Löcher haben.
Ich rolle jetzt noch mal drüber in der Hoffnung, dass er reißt.
Das ist leider ein Fondant, der nicht so reißt.
Ein Nachteil dieses Mal.
Aber seht ihr es?
Der ist so ein bisschen angetrocknet.
Und wenn ich jetzt so drübergehe, wird er rissig.
Ich hoffe, das sieht dann auch gewollt gut aus.
Ich probiere es dann einfach
vielleicht da noch so ein bisschen.
Und dann machen wir da gleich eine coole Struktur rein.
Hier jetzt auch ein bisschen Backtrennspray,
damit der Fondant haftet.
Beim Sprühen übrigens immer darauf achten,
die Flasche aufrecht zu halten.
Wenn ihr nämlich so macht
oder so,
dann entweicht das Gas,
aber es kommt dann kein Öl raus.
Und irgendwann habt ihr dann nur noch das Öl drin
und kein Gas mehr.
Das Öl kommt dann zwar raus,
aber es wird eben nicht mehr so fein gesprüht.
Und es ist wirklich ein reines Kokos- und Rapsöl.
Und da ist einfach so ein Triebmittel drin,
dass es eben aus der Flasche rauskommt.
Jetzt hoffe ich zum ersten Mal, dass er reißt.
Ja, das gab es auch noch nicht in Sallys Welt.
Aber ich sehe schon,
der hat schon so eine Lederoptik.
Und hier jetzt schön die Luft ausstreichen.
Und dann glatt streichen.
[Musik]
Und ihr könnt ihn jetzt aber wieder zusammenkneten
und beim nächsten Mal weiter benutzen.
Denn so angetrocknet,
so sehr angetrocknet war es jetzt auch nicht.
Okay.
Und jetzt mit Fondantglättern schön glatt machen.
Ah, ich sehe schon, es klappt.
Guckt. Das ist eigentlich das, was man nie möchte,
dass der Fondant rissig wird und trocken wird.
Aber hier an der Oberfläche finde ich es jetzt perfekt.
Ich hoffe, es verstärkt sich jetzt noch
durch das Glätten.
[Musik]
Nach unten streichen, sodass ich einfach
einen schönen rechten Winkel bekomme.
[Musik]
Guckt mal. Wenn ihr hier seitlich Luftbläschen habt,
dann könnt ihr die bei der Upside-Down-Methode
nämlich ganz schön rausstreichen.
Dann kommen die hier oben raus
und dann sind sie weg.
Dann müsst ihr sie nicht aufschneiden.
[Musik]
So die dritte Torte
ist dann schon
heftig.
Okay.
Diese unperfekt perfekte Torte
stelle ich jetzt in den Kühlschrank.
Ich sage deswegen unperfekt perfekt,
weil jetzt habe ich endlich diese Risse drin!
Yay!
Ich glaube, ich habe mich noch nie so sehr
über Fondantrisse gefreut wie hier.
Und später kann ich,
wenn der Fondant jetzt leicht antrocknet im Kühlschrank,
die Torte fertig dekorieren.
Aber das mache ich wahrscheinlich erst morgen.
Und jetzt kümmere ich mich noch um die andere Torte.
Dip, dip, dip, dip,
tschu, dü, dü.
[Musik]
A, a, a!
>> SARAH: Und jetzt alle!
>> SALLY: Und jetzt alle!
>> ALLE: A!
>> SARAH: A!
Ich glaube, du musst...
>> SALLY: Du bist Altstimme.
A!
>> SALLY & AYLIN: A!
>> SALLY: A!
Eins, zwei, drei!
>> ALLE: A!
>> SARAH: Volkan
strengt sich hier an.
>> SALLY: Wunderbar!
>> SARAH: Weil er muss da immer so darüber lachen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> SARAH: Er freut sich ja.
>> SALLY: Jetzt geht es mit der Torte weiter.
Und zwar ist die Ganache jetzt wirklich schön fest.
Und am besten nehmt ihr jetzt eure Hände
und streicht die Ganache hier schön glatt.
Dann bekommt ihr nämlich auch den Fondant schön glatt hin.
Das heißt, hier wirklich über die Stellen drüber.
Und das geht mit einer Palette einfach nicht so ganz gut.
Und ich gucke da auch immer auf die Vorlage,
damit ich wirklich
die Gesichtszüge so gut wie möglich hinbekomme.
[Musik]
Immer wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen Zeit habe,
weil zum Beispiel was kühlen muss,
kann ich schon mal eine Deko herstellen.
Und jetzt habe ich hier schwarzen Fondant.
Daraus mache ich Harrys Brille.
Also jetzt geht es im Prinzip
erst mal so richtig los mit der Harry-Potter-Torte.
Denn ich muss ja noch die ganzen Dekoelemente machen.
Gut, der Hut ist schon Harry Potter.
Aber so alles andere.
Also ich habe jetzt hier schwarzen Fondant.
Und damit der schön aushärtet wie Blütenpaste,
habe ich hier CMC eingeknetet.
Das ist einfach so ein Pulver,
Cellulose.
Dadurch härtet es aus.
Ich habe jetzt ein bisschen viel genommen.
Wird schnell hart.
Aber ist jetzt nicht schlimm.
Und das rolle ich jetzt hier 3 mm dick aus.
Ich habe hier einfach diese Abstandsringe
auf dem Ausrollstab,
kann hier einmal drüberrollen
und dann wird die Brille schön gleichmäßig dick.
[Musik]
Und dann nehme ich jetzt hier einfach zwei Ausstecher,
kann erst mal zwei Kreise ausstechen
und dann den inneren Kreis entfernen.
Ups!
Keine Blume.
[Musik]
Und aus dem Rest schneide ich jetzt noch die Bügel aus.
Ich habe jetzt hier schon mal eine Seite geglättet.
Die könnt ihr euch jetzt hier oben an die Matte dranlegen
und dann den rechten Winkel der Backmatte
oder der Silikonmatte einfach benutzen.
Ich nehme jetzt hier eine Teigkarte.
Die ist nämlich auch schön gerade.
Und dann einfach durchdrücken.
Ich mache noch mal zwei zum Ersatz,
falls da was bricht oder so.
Und das Zusammenkleben der Brille mache ich natürlich erst,
wenn alles getrocknet ist.
Jetzt noch alle schön einheitlich zuschneiden,
also der Länge nach.
Und ich biege die jetzt unten einfach so ein bisschen zu
– zurecht.
Wie sagt man da? Zurecht.
Hier noch das Mittelteil
für die Brille hier in der Mitte,
für über die Nase.
Das biege ich auch ein bisschen.
Und dann können die Teile hier schon mal trocknen.
Schokolade innen und Schokolade außen.
Ich nehme jetzt hier Schokoladenfondant.
Der schmeckt echt megalecker
wie Storck Riesen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr die kennt,
diese schwarzen Bonbons.
Okay.
Und ich habe das jetzt hier schon weich geknetet.
Und ich mache es jetzt so
– ich gucke immer wieder rüber,
weil ich da das Bild habe auf dem Laptop.
Ich werde zuerst mal hier oben die kleine Spitze machen
und dann den Rest überziehen.
Denn die Spitze, da ist dann wie so ein Absatz,
also so gefaltet.
Also hier kurz ausrollen.
Da jetzt nicht zu dünn ausrollen,
damit ihr einfach schön Platz habt
und ein bisschen Raum habt,
um das Ganze auch in Falten zu legen.
Gerade sage ich: "Die Flasche nicht auf den Kopf"
und dann halte ich sie über Kopf.
Also jetzt erst mal hier den oberen Part.
[Musik]
Und wirklich schön hier Falten reinmachen.
Also so mit den Fingern
immer ein bisschen zusammendrücken
und dann bekommt ihr diese Lederfalten hin.
Dann
ein großes Stück Fondant.
[Musik]
O Gott! Jetzt muss ich alles ertasten.
Auge? Auge?
Hier.
[Musik]
Hier hinten lege ich einfach den Rest so drüber
und schneide dann alle Überreste weg.
Das darf wirklich auch ein bisschen unordentlich aussehen.
Hauptsache, hinten ist alles zu.
[Musik]
Und ihr könnt dann sogar mit so einem kleinen Werkzeug
eine Naht anzeichnen.
[Musik]
Ich schneide jetzt hier noch mal die Reste unten weg,
so nur ganz großzügig.
Ich überlege mir schon mal, wie ich unten diesen Hut-
– wie heißt das denn jetzt?
Hutschaft?
Ich weiß es immer noch nicht –
das außenrum da beim Hut hinmache.
Ich möchte den ja später, wie gesagt, als dritte Torte
auf die anderen zwei setzen.
Und ich nehme jetzt einen Tortenretter.
Denn der ist schön dünn, aber eben trotzdem stabil.
Und ich glaube, den sieht man dann einfach nicht drunter.
Ich habe ja hier drunter noch das Ganaching Board.
Ich nehme jetzt die Torte hier rüber
vorsichtig.
[Musik]
Und hier habe ich noch etwas Schokofondant.
Und wie hieß jetzt das außenrum, Josh?
>> JOSH: Hutkrempe.
>> SALLY: Krempe, Hutkrempe.
Jetzt kommt die Hutkrempe dran.
[Musik]
Und die Naht mache ich jetzt auch wieder da hinten einfach.
So.
Der Rest weg.
Und dann einfach
beim Tortenretter hier abschneiden
oder sogar ein bisschen überhängen lassen.
Das sieht, glaube ich, auch ganz gut aus.
[Musik]
Und jetzt mache ich noch mal ein langes Band,
schneide es zu und lege es hier einmal um den Hut.
Und dann ist der Hut erst mal fertig
und kann morgen dann in aller Ruhe schattiert werden.
Das macht am meisten Spaß,
weil da sieht man wirklich noch mal so einen krassen Effekt.
Also so sieht er schon, finde ich, ganz gut aus.
Aber, wenn er schattiert wird, sieht er
hammermäßig aus!
Ja.
[Musik]
Das war es, meine Lieben!
Das war der Hut
zumindest für heute.
Warte.
Heute ist nicht alle Tage,
ich komm wieder, keine Frage!
Also bis morgen!
Jetzt räumen wir hier auf,
machen noch eine Karaoke-Einheit.
Dann geht es mir einfach wieder besser.
Und dann sehen wir uns morgen wieder.
Das muss ich einmal noch machen
mit dem Hut-so-Aufsetzen.
Aber das machen wir morgen,
wenn mir jemand beim Tragen hilft.
Sonst flups
auf den Boden.
Heute ist Tag drei
in Hogwarts.
Ja.
Und wir starten den Tag mit Apple Crumble
etwas gesünder als sonst.
Also wir nehmen jetzt keinen normalen Zucker,
sondern machen so ein wirklich Frühstücks-Apple-Crumble.
Ich mache das jetzt so nebenher.
Und dann geht es gleich mit dem Hut weiter.
Huch!
Sarah ist nämlich auch gleich da.
Dann wird der Hut fotografiert.
Ich habe jetzt hier schon Äpfel und Zitronensaft.
Zimt nehmen wir noch rein.
So.
Und ich mache das jetzt hier einfach mit Dinkelmehl,
Haferflocken, Mandeln, Nüssen,
ein bisschen Tonka Wonka,
– vegan –
ein Stückchen vegane Butter
und ein bisschen Dattelsirup.
Dann können nämlich Dennis und Volkan auch mitessen.
[Musik]
Das ist wie so ein gebackenes Müsli mit Äpfeln jetzt.
Und jetzt ist das Frühstück gleich fertig
und wir machen an der Torte weiter.
[Musik]
Jetzt wird der sprechende Hut schattiert.
Dafür habe ich jetzt braune und schwarze Lebensmittelfarbe
in Pulverform.
Das Ganze wird jetzt nämlich trocken aufgetupft.
Wundert euch übrigens nicht über den Volkan hier
und über Sarah hinter mir.
Wir machen gerade noch Fotos direkt.
Zeig dich, Volkan. Komm.
Komm, komm.
Volkan,
er möchte nicht erkannt werden.
V.
A., er möchte nicht erkannt werden.
Genau. Wir machen gerade noch Fotos für den Katalog,
für den nächsten.
Okay.
Jetzt nehmt ihr die Farben.
Ich habe jetzt hier Braun und Schwarz.
Braun bräuchte man theoretisch nicht.
Aber ich mische das auch immer ganz gerne.
Und alles, was jetzt hier Tiefe hat,
also die Augen, der Mund, die Falten
werden jetzt im Prinzip schattiert,
sodass sie noch mehr Tiefe halt bekommen.
Ja.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und ich starte da immer
erst mal sehr vorsichtig mit der Farbe.
Und dann wirklich nur ganz langsam dunkler werden.
So.
So, Sarah?
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und hier in der Mitte eher dunkler
und dann nach außen hin wieder heller werden.
Guck mal. Das sieht man jetzt schon ganz gut.
Das macht schon einen Unterschied
– nicht? – so.
Die Seite ist jetzt schon schattiert
und die noch nicht.
Sieht man es von vorne?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, es macht ihm Spaß.
>> SARAH: Ich glaube, er hält gern ein Styropor.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> VOLKAN: Ach so. Wohin damit?
Soll ich das so hinstellen?
>> SARAH: Zu mir.
>> SALLY: Sarah ist die Styroporheldin.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Wir haben uns gedacht,
normalerweise passiert so was immer so hinter der Kamera.
Aber warum sollt ihr nicht auch sehen,
was hier ständig für ein Wahnsinn herrscht?
Volkan, hast du schon einen Song?
>> VOLKAN: Einen Song?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> VOLKAN: Was für einen Song?
>> SALLY: Einen Karaoke-Song.
Jeder, der hier arbeitet,
muss hier singen!
Denn Musik macht uns
>> VOLKAN: Ja?
>> SALLY: glücklich?
>> VOLKAN: Mama.
Ja, okay.
Um zwei? Ah ja. Hm.
Ich komme später noch mal, okay?
>> SALLY: Da-da-daa, da-da-daa,
d-da-da-daa, d-da-da-daa!
Irgendwann singe ich noch so einen Märchensong.
Sarah?
>> SARAH: Hm?
>> SALLY: Welche Märchenfigur bist du?
>> SARAH: Das weiß ich wirklich nicht.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Der sprechende Hut ist fertig.
Ja. Ich bin zufrieden.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich ja den sprechenden Hut gebacken.
Im Film spricht er ja auch wirklich.
Er entscheidet ja, wer in welches Haus kommt.
Ich probiere es mal.
Vielleicht ist er ansprechbar.
Hallo?
Hut!
Ich meine, der ist ja aus Schokolade.
Vielleicht kann ich ihn
wecken mit
Vanilleextrakt.
Ich würde schon wach werden davon,
wenn mir das jemand unter die Nase hält.
[Musik]
[Hut gähnt]
Hallo?
>> HUT: Na,
>> SALLY: Hut?
>> HUT: wenn haben wir denn da?
Die Sally.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich habe mir gedacht, vielleicht kannst du mir sagen,
in welches Haus ich passen würde.
>> HUT: Mh.
Da muss ich kurz überlegen.
Hm.
Wenn ich mir die Torten von eben gerade so anschaue,
dann bist du für mich
ein kleiner Streber
und gehörst
>> SALLY: Hallo?!
>> HUT: in das Haus Ravenclaw.
>> SALLY: Ravenclaw? Zu den Strebern?
>> HUT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich meine, ich bin schon fleißig und ehrgeizig.
Aber ein Streber bin ich nicht.
>> HUT: Mh.
>> SALLY: Nö.
Nein, da passe ich nicht rein.
>> HUT: Mh.
Nicht?
>> SALLY: Nein.
Was gibt es noch?
>> HUT: Ja, mh.
Dann vielleicht Hufflepuff?
Da kommen so verträumte,
so...
>> SALLY: Hallo?! Sehe ich aus wie ein Träumer?!
Da könnte man doch
Murat und Güni hinschicken.
>> HUT: Murat und Güni zusammen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Oh!
>> SALLY & HUT: Nee, nee.
>> SALLY: Komm. Ah, falsche Überlegung.
>> HUT: Die zwei machen das Haus kaputt.
>> SALLY: Mh, aber Streber passt auch nicht bei beiden.
Dann lass doch einen von beiden dort,
Güni zum Beispiel
und Murat ins nächste
>> HUT: Murat nach Gryffindor?
Gryffindor
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> HUT: hätte ich noch übrig.
Dann bleibt aber für dich nur noch Slytherin.
>> SALLY: Oh nee!
In Slytherin, da sind doch die ganzen Bösen drin!
Nee, da will ich auch nicht hin.
>> HUT: Dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Also wir haben nur vier Häuser.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> HUT: Dann musst du wohl
in deinem Haus in Waghäusel bleiben.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Dann bleibe ich da.
Dann schicken wir Murat und Güni weg
und ich bleibe in meinem Haus hier.
>> HUT: Gut.
>> SALLY: Bleibst du auch da?
>> HUT: Ich bleibe bei dir.
>> SALLY: Dürfen wir dich dann essen?
>> HUT: Mh.
Mh.
Mh, mh.
Ja, vielleicht.
>> SALLY: Ach, gut.
Jetzt komme ich zu Gleis 9 3/4.
Die Torte ist ja bereits überzogen
und war über Nacht im Kühlschrank.
Ich habe jetzt hier roten Fondant und schwarzen.
Denn ich möchte jetzt Backsteine nachahmen
beziehungsweise sogar richtige Backsteine machen.
Volkan!
>> VOLKAN: Die Fondantmaschine.
>> SALLY: Die Fondantmaschine!
Liebe Männer, ihr tut euren Frauen einen Gefallen,
wenn ihr nach dem Händewaschen
das Waschbecken wieder schön trocken reibt.
So und so.
>> VOLKAN: Morgen muss ich
wirklich schon daheim anfangen.
>> SALLY: Und so.
>> VOLKAN: Die wundert sich.
>> SALLY: Bei seiner Mama, nicht bei seiner Freundin.
Er hat keine Freundin.
>> VOLKAN: Ja, genau. So sieht es aus.
>> SALLY: Ich wollte es nur klarstellen.
Die mache ich jetzt drauf, damit die Ziegelsteine,
die Backsteine alle gleich dick werden,
alle 3 mm dick.
Ist schon anstrengend, gell?
>> VOLKAN: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich habe das früher immer alleine gemacht,
alles alleine.
>> VOLKAN: Echt?
>> SALLY: Und die Kamera und Stativ.
Ja.
Nebenher das geknetet.
Dann habe ich halt für so eine Torte eine Woche gebraucht.
Und dann mache ich es auch so, dass...
Das soll so ein bisschen
wie die Wand da hinten, so wie diese Backsteinwand
schon so ein bisschen Struktur haben
>> VOLKAN: Okay.
>> SALLY: und Farbverläufe.
Und jetzt mit Bäckerstärke ausrollen.
Und das muss jetzt hier gar nicht so glatt sein,
denn Klinker sind ja auch nicht glatt.
Daher gebe ich mir da jetzt nicht so viel Mühe,
das jetzt glatt zu machen.
Jetzt habe ich hier, wie gesagt, diese 3-mm-Abstandsringe.
Dann werden sie gleichmäßig dick.
Sehr gut! Ich bin stolz auf dich.
[Musik]
Backen ist voll der Sport!
>> VOLKAN: Übertrieben!
>> SALLY: Ja, ich habe jetzt hier schon...
>> VOLKAN: Zeig mal.
Ich glaube, das reicht. Sonst platzt dein Hemd.
>> SALLY: Hemd geplatzt.
Und jetzt ziehe ich es hier rüber.
Denn auf der Silikonmatte dürft ihr niemals schneiden.
Und jetzt schneide ich die Klinker zu.
Und ich glaube, ich mache sie wirklich relativ klein
so wie bei mir an der Wand.
Also nehme ich jetzt hier das Bisiklet
und schneide hier die Streifen zu.
Wenn ihr das nicht habt, nehmt ihr einfach ein Pizzarad
oder ein Lineal zum Beispiel.
Es dauert dann halt nur ein bisschen länger.
Denn hier kann ich jetzt vier Streifen auf einmal zuschneiden.
Ich habe jetzt hier ein bisschen Bäckerstärke drauf.
Und ihr könnt auch die Platte gerne antrocknen lassen.
Dann schneidet sich es besser.
[Musik]
So, nachdem du den Backworkshop
hier bei mir absolviert hast,
kannst du den Konditormeister machen,
den Malermeister,
den Maurer
und Fitnesstrainer.
[Musik]
Jetzt mache ich noch den goldenen Schnatz.
Das ist der hier.
Eigentlich habe ich mir überlegt, ich nehme den für die Deko.
Aber nein, ich zeige euch, wie ich den mache.
Zuerst hatte ich mir überlegt,
diese runden Pralinen zu nehmen,
diese Lindor, aber die sind zu klein.
Also nehme ich jetzt hier die Kuchenreste
und bin eigentlich ganz froh,
dass wir sie nicht schon aufgegessen haben.
Ihr könnt zum Beispiel auch einfach
nur den Schnatz machen als Cake-Pops.
Ja, ich mache jetzt nicht so viele.
So.
Schön zerbröseln.
[Musik]
Und dann nehme ich Ganache.
Und da nehme ich jetzt einfach nur so viel,
dass eine klebrige Masse entsteht.
Hach!
Ich sage es schon wieder.
Ihr könnt auch eine größere Schüssel nehmen.
Bevor sie gekleckert hat,
hat sie doch eine größere Schüssel genommen.
Und jetzt hier schön mit der Ganache verbinden.
Jetzt nehme ich den großen Eisportionierer
und fülle den einmal flach damit
und forme das jetzt hier schön zu einer Kugel,
so rund wie nur möglich.
Guckt mal. Wenn ihr sie in irgendwas reinlegt,
was unten eben auch schön rund ist,
dann werden sie nicht flach unten.
[Musik]
Ich habe hier jetzt noch etwas Ganache,
weiße Ganache.
Die erwärme ich jetzt.
Denn das wird jetzt mein Fugenmaterial
– ups! –
für die Klinker.
Ah, ich bin ja nur noch am Sauerei machen hier.
Wer will fleißige Handwerker sehen,
der muss zu der Sally gehen!
O wie fein, o wie fein!
Der Maler streicht die Wände...
Das war falsch.
O wie fein, o wie fein!
Der Glaser setzt die Scheiben ein!
Hi!
>> VOLKAN: Hallo!
Magst du auch was trinken?
>> SALLY: Ja, ich habe hier mein Dubbeglas
mit Wasser.
>> VOLKAN: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Tschüss!
Perfekt!
Guckt einmal! So muss Fugenmasse aussehen.
Ups!
Habe ich etwa gekleckert?
Sehr gut!
Und jetzt machen wir eine Kamerafahrt.
>> JOSH: Nein! Ich kann doch nicht
>> SALLY: Wuhuhu!
>> JOSH: so weit.
>> SALLY: Es macht mich glücklich, euch satt zu machen.
>> DENNIS: Oh, danke, Mama.
>> SALLY: Der hat mich jetzt nicht Mama genannt, oder?
>> DENNIS: Doch.
Das ist so fürsorglich.
>> SALLY: Hast du mich jetzt Mama genannt, ja?
>> DENNIS: Ja.
>> SALLY: Das hat jetzt alles zwischen uns kaputt gemacht.
Kommt, meine Kinder! Kommt!
>> DENNIS: Danke, Mama!
>> SARAH: Vielen Dank!
>> SALLY: Ich finde es halt schön, Menschen satt zu machen.
>> VOLKAN: ... Witze über andere zu machen.
>> DENNIS: Mann, eh! Sei mal nicht so eine Zicke!
Ohne Spaß!
>> VOLKAN: Ich will nicht mehr mit dir zusammenarbeiten.
>> DENNIS: Ja.
Dann geh!
Du bist richtig gemein, Volkan!
>> SALLY: Da-daa, da-daa!
Wir sind mittlerweile wie so eine Sitcom, nicht?
>> SARAH: Ja!
>> SALLY: Das ist so: Hey, willkommen in...
>> DENNIS: Gabel oder ein...
>> SALLY: Löffel, Gabel, egal.
Du kannst es auch noch mal warm machen.
>> DENNIS: Sarah, brauchst du einen Löffel?
Ich auch wahrscheinlich.
>> SALLY: Jetzt habe ich hier also die große Torte.
Und da kommt jetzt ein bisschen Spachtelmasse drauf.
Und durch die kalte Torte
zieht das auch gleich an.
Besser wäre es jetzt, ihr hättet jetzt schon
einen Untergrund für die Torte,
also schon auf einem Cake Board.
Und die Torte hättet ihr jetzt auch
ohne Fondant machen können.
Aber so ist sie einfach noch mal geschützter
und ich habe hier obendrauf eben auch die Schicht.
Also da dürft ihr gerne selbst entscheiden,
wie ihr die machen wollt.
Und jetzt diese Steine ankleben,
so ein bisschen versetzt.
Und die zweite Reihe kommt dann hier so mittig drüber.
Und dann sieht man so ein bisschen die Fugenmasse raus.
[Musik]
Ich wollte das ursprünglich draufmalen,
aber ich glaube, einfacher ist es,
ich mache das jetzt mit Blütenpaste.
Ich habe nämlich schon Blütenpaste ausgerollt.
Guckt. Hier,
ganz dünn.
Und das Harry-Potter-Logo mache ich auch gleich.
Und ich glaube, das hier
drucke ich mir auch kurz aus.
Und dann kann ich es schön abmalen.
Ich gucke nur noch wegen
"Hogwarts Express" und "Platform",
ob ich das auch hinschreibe.
Aber
ja, ich schicke das kurz Siamak rüber nach oben.
Dann kann er es mir ausdrucken.
Ich habe nämlich unten keinen Drucker.
Siamak.
Hier habe ich das Harry-Potter-Logo.
Und ich versuche es jetzt sogar hier drunterzulegen.
Ja.
Ich kann es schön abpausen
und einfach drumherumschneiden.
Hier gucke ich auch noch ein bisschen.
[Musik]
Ihr seht, das Ausgeschnittene, das klappt wirklich super.
Aber dafür muss wirklich die Blütenpaste
oder der Fondant einfach schön lange trocknen.
Es ist noch nicht ganz trocken.
Ihr seht, das ist noch ein bisschen flexibel.
Aber dadurch, dass die Oberfläche
und die Unterseite angetrocknet ist,
lässt es sich echt gut schneiden und verzieht sich nicht so.
Das kann ich jetzt hier noch ein bisschen antrocknen lassen.
Beziehungsweise ich könnte es sogar...
Mh.
Nö, ich lasse es noch antrocknen.
Und später kommt dann Gold drüber.
Aber ich mache das jetzt so,
dass es nicht komplett trocknet.
Denn ich will es ja später an die Torte kleben.
Dann kommt es zur Seite.
Und dann mache ich jetzt noch Platform 9 3/4.
>> ELA: Machen?
>> SALLY: Mh? Was möchtest du machen?
>> ELA: Kann ich auch?
>> SALLY: Ich mache gerade eine Harry-Potter-Torte.
Kennst du Harry Potter?
>> ELA: Nein.
>> SALLY: Du bist auch noch zu jung.
>> ELA: Aber dafür will ich was anderes machen.
>> SALLY: Was willst du machen?
>> ELA: Auch was aus dem machen.
>> SALLY: Aus Fondant?
Guck mal. Ich kann dir hier die Reste geben.
Die kannst du ausstechen.
[Musik]
>> ELA: Ich brauche mehr Fondant!
>> SALLY: Mehr Fondant?
>> ELA: Das ist zu wenig.
>> SALLY: Volkan abi gibt dir.
Oder guck mal zum Josh.
Vielleicht hat er auch.
>> VOLKAN: Um was geht es?
>> ELA: Er hat keins.
>> VOLKAN: Was denn?
>> ELA: Ich gehe es selber holen dort hinten.
>> SALLY: Ich zeichne jetzt erst mal
mit Lebensmittelfarbstiften das hier alles auf
[Musik]
Ich habe mir jetzt was überlegt.
Ich mache jetzt hier die Schrift schwarz auf weiß
und mache dann noch eine schwarze Umrandung.
Denn weiß auf schwarz ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Also...
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich das hier
und nehme noch mal ein bisschen Pulver,
um das Ganze so ein bisschen schmutzig zu machen.
Also so einfach so ein bisschen drüberpudern,
dass es nicht ganz so neu aussieht.
Und dann kann ich Gleis 9 3/4
direkt an die Torte ankleben mit essbarem Kleber.
Da sucht ihr euch die schönste Seite aus,
die ihr vorne haben wollt.
Den Kleber wirklich sparsam benutzen.
Der ist sehr ergiebig.
Ich verteile den dann gern noch so ein bisschen.
Das Krasse ist, ich habe vorhin nicht mal ausgemessen,
ob das passt.
Ich habe das voll vergessen.
Das war jetzt einfach Außenmaß.
Normalerweise hätte ich es noch vorgetestet.
Perfekt!
Ich habe zum Siamak nur gesagt:
"Ach, druck so 10 cm."
Supi!
Das ist das untere Stockwerk!
[Musik]
>> SIAMAK: Habt ihr alle angeguckt?
>> SALLY: Ich habe nicht alle angeguckt.
Aber ich weiß, was die Winkelgasse ist,
wo sich die Steine so
– okay, Josh hat mich daran erinnert.
Muss ich zugeben.
Winkelgasse, da verschieben sich so die Steine.
Ja.
Hier ist jetzt Plattform 9 3/4
– Gleis 9 3/4.
Und die Rückseite ist Winkelgasse.
Siehst du? Passt alles.
So. Ich bin würde sagen, Sarah fotografiert,
Volkan und ich, wir machen Karaoke-Pause.
Er haut ab.
Warum?!
[Musik]
Los! Du kannst das besser. Ich kann nicht so hoch singen.
You're gonna miss me when I'm
>> SALLY & Ela: gone.
>> SALLY: When I'm gone.
When I'm gone.
You're gonna miss me when I'm gone.
Ich kann das nicht.
You're gonna miss me by my walk.
You're gonna miss me by my talk, oh.
>> ELA: Oh!
>> SALLY: You're gonna miss me when I'm
>> SALLY & Ela: gone.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Jetzt gleich wieder: I got my ticket.
>> ELA: I got my ticket for the long way 'round.
>> SALLY: Two...
>> ELA: You're gonna miss me when I'm away.
And I sure can't lie the other way.
You're gonna miss me when I'm gone.
Ah!
>> SALLY & DENNIS: Rock your body right!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Backstreet's
>> SALLY & DENNIS: back alright!
>> SALLY: You're gonna miss me when I'm gone.
You're gonna miss me by my hair.
You're gonna miss me everywhere, oh.
You're gonna miss me when I'm gone!
Los?
>> ELA: Mach du.
>> SALLY: Rock your body right!
>> DENNIS: Right!
>> SALLY & DENNIS: Backstreet's back alright!
>> SALLY: Jetzt mache ich den goldenen Schnatz
weiter.
Denn ich habe ja schon angefangen.
Die Kugeln sind schön hart.
Und jetzt nehme ich hier Blütenpaste und Fondant.
Das Ganze habe ich schon gemischt eins zu eins.
Nicht zu dünn.
Denn ich will jetzt die Kugel damit einkleiden.
Und der Part wird jetzt hier drübergezogen.
Ist am Anfang etwas schwierig wegen den Falten.
Also wirklich so versuchen,
so faltenfrei wie möglich hinzukriegen.
Aber natürlich muss ich an der Unterseite
die Falten zusammenraffen.
Und dann zwirble ich sie einfach weg
und versuche, es jetzt hier so glatt zu drücken.
[Musik]
Die Kugel lege ich jetzt kurz zur Seite
und mache jetzt schon mal die Flügel.
Wenn ihr Fondant und Blütenpaste mischt,
dann könnt ihr es auch wirklich viel, viel dünner ausrollen.
Das kommt durch die Blütenpaste.
Jetzt gucke ich mir kurz die Flügel an.
Also oben so rund
und dann hinten so ein bisschen geschwungener.
Jetzt muss ich tatsächlich
>> MURAT: Das kann man nicht essen.
>> JOSH: Ja, klar.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: Aber Glucose, Fructose, Zucker...
>> SALLY: Ja, der Josh hat nicht unrecht.
Denn ich arbeite normalerweise immer
mit essbaren Dingen in der Küche.
Immer.
Das ist jetzt das einzige Mal, wo ich wirklich zaubern muss.
Denn ich brauche jetzt Draht,
damit ich diese Rundung hinbekomme.
Zahnstocher würden nämlich alles kaputt machen.
Erst mal halbieren.
Und
dann mache ich hier so eine Rundung
Kann ich dir helfen?
So. Dann mache ich das hier so
und so,
also wie so ein geschwungenes Dreieck.
Und dann nehme ich jetzt Kleber,
wieder den essbaren.
Das kommt hier oben an den Rand.
[Musik]
Dann kommt hier der Draht rein
und wird so eingewickelt.
So haben die das bestimmt bei Harry Potter auch gemacht.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Gell?
>> SALLY: Also guckt auf jeden Fall,
dass euer Draht
ein bisschen länger ist.
Und hier schön flach drücken.
Mh.
Guckt!
>> VOLKAN: Bist du glücklich?
>> SALLY: Von der Größe her, ist das zu groß?
Geht eigentlich, nicht?
Weil der ist ja auch klein und die Flügel sind riesig.
Und jetzt würde ich aber noch
– der hat ja auch so wie so Federn dran –
das hier so ein bisschen einschneiden,
so eindrücken.
Nicht bis ganz hoch,
dass das nicht so ganz zerbrechlich wird,
aber schon filigran.
Ich könnte so voll die Filmrequisite machen.
Ich mache gerade Filmrequisite,
>> MURAT: Ach so.
>> SALLY: den goldenen Schnatz.
[Musik]
Und dann kann ich nämlich
mit dem Pinsel den Kleber hier aufzeichnen.
[Musik]
Ich kann hier jetzt eh so schlecht sitzen.
Aber ich muss jetzt ein bisschen runter
und mache einfach jetzt noch so ein paar Querstreifen.
Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, da
bin ich jetzt nicht so genau.
Da gucke ich jetzt einfach, dass es gut aussieht,
dass man erkennt, was es ist.
Aber ich mache jetzt nicht jeden Streifen so genau,
wie sich es gehört.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt hier die Brillenteile und etwas Isomalt.
Isomalt ist ein Zuckeraustauschstoff,
der einfach eine andere Schmelzeigenschaft hat,
also einen anderen Schmelzpunkt als Zucker.
Das heißt, der schmilzt,
aber karamellisiert einfach nicht so schnell.
Und deswegen ist der perfekt geeignet,
um zum Beispiel Gläser zu gießen
oder um auch ein Lebkuchenhaus zusammenzukleben.
Denn Zucker ist einfach schön flüssig, wenn er heiß ist,
und wird schnell fest, wenn er abkühlt.
Das heißt, ihr habt wirklich sofort ein Ergebnis,
sofort diese Klebkraft.
Und ich benutze den Zucker
zum einen, um die Gläser zu füllen.
Ich meine, ihr könnt sie auch so lassen,
aber so mit einer Scheibe drin sieht es schon cooler aus.
Und ich benutze ihn auch gleich,
um eben das zusammenzukleben.
Jetzt warte ich eben, bis er schmilzt.
Hi, ich bin Harry.
>> SARAH: Sag mal einen Zauberspruch.
>> SALLY: Arachnophobia.
Nein, das war kein Zauberspruch.
>> SARAH: Wingardium Leviosa.
>> SALLY: Wingardium Leviosa.
Das heißt Leviosaa.
>> SARAH: Wie du uns Türkisch beibringst.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Ich probiere es.
Ich hoffe, das geht halt hier auf dem Wachspapier.
Ich glaube, ich probiere erst mal.
Denn ich will es jetzt nicht auf mein Backpapier gießen.
Mein Backpapier ist nämlich strukturiert.
Die Folie hat auch eine leichte Struktur.
Ich brauche jetzt was schönes Glattes.
Ich habe jetzt hier Wachspapier.
Vielleicht habt ihr auch glattes Backpapier.
Guckt. So sieht das jetzt gerade aus.
Und das ist jetzt wirklich schön glasklar.
Und ich probiere es jetzt einfach mal kurz hier zu gießen,
lasse es geschwind aushärten
und gucke, ob es sich ablöst.
[Musik]
Also war gut, dass ich es ausprobiert habe.
Denn
auf Wachspapier klebt es leider.
Ich nehme jetzt doch meine Dauerbackfolie.
Die hat zwar ein bisschen Struktur,
aber dann hat er halt Strukturgläser.
Egal.
Also hier einmal,
zweimal.
Und da kommt das jetzt rein.
[Musik]
Ich klopfe die Luftbläschen raus, so weit es geht.
Ich bin ja kein Glasgießer.
Und so.
Da war es jetzt besser, denn da hatte ich auch mehr
vom Glas.
Seht ihr? Da ist es richtig schön glatt
und hier nicht, denn hier hatte ich zu wenig Masse
und die war auch schon ein bisschen zu kalt.
Ich wollte mir eigentlich schon von Anfang an
so hier so einen Blitz hinmalen.
>> SARAH: Das wäre schon gut.
>> JOSH: Stimmt.
>> SARAH: Das kannst du jetzt machen.
>> SALLY: Hm, zum Schluss.
Zum Schluss machen wir das.
>> JOSH: Wir machen es in der Szene mit dem Hut.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja, genau. Okay.
Jetzt mache ich hier mit der mittleren Torte weiter.
Das hier wird ja so eine Betonoptik.
Daher ja der rissige Fondant.
Hier habe ich das Logo.
Und das besprühe ich jetzt mit Metallic Farbe
in Kupfer und Gold.
Ihr könnt es aber auch mit Pulverfarben machen,
also, wie ihr wollt.
Ich mache jetzt beides.
Ich nehme jetzt erst mal hier Gold
Metallic Spray.
Natürlich alles Lebensmittelfarben.
Und da auch darauf achten, dass ihr die Dose so haltet
und nicht so.
Denn ansonsten entweicht das Gas,
die Farbe bleibt drinnen
und irgendwann habt ihr einfach nichts mehr
von eurem Produkt.
Ich meine, so ein bisschen neigen muss ich es auch.
Und ihr seht, man braucht wirklich nur ganz, ganz, ganz wenig.
Ich nehme jetzt noch ein bisschen Kupfer drauf.
Das Ganze soll ein bisschen alt aussehen.
So.
Und dann
nehme ich jetzt einen trockenen Pinsel
und habe hier noch trockene Pulverfarben
in Schwarz, Braun, Bronze und Gold.
Und damit strukturiere ich hier jetzt noch die Torte.
[Musik]
Gibst du mir den Schnatz? Snitch?
Der fliegt weg!
Ah, der kann noch gar nicht fliegen. Der hat keine Flügel.
Der Schnatz.
Komm jetzt machen wir den golden.
Das machen wir jetzt so.
[Quietschen]
Das war der.
Also jetzt sprühe ich erst mal
beim Schnatz die Unterseite ein,
lasse es trocknen
und dann die Oberseite
und natürlich auch die Flügel.
Und bei den Flügeln auch erst mal die Rückseite.
So.
Und nach der Trockenzeit dann die Vorderseite.
Und solang räume ich jetzt auf.
Also wir.
Gell?
Was ich jetzt mache, bitte ganz vorsichtig machen.
Denn ich nehme jetzt auch dieses Isomalt,
also den Zucker, um die Brille zusammenzukleben,
und halte jetzt hier das Teil in der Hand,
aber sehr vorsichtig,
damit ich mich nicht schon wieder an Karamell verbrenne.
[Musik]
Ich finde, die Brille, die darf auch so ein bisschen
so verklebt aussehen, denn
die sah halt im Film auch nicht so toll aus, muss ich sagen.
Und wie gesagt, habt ihr den Vorteil,
dass es wirklich sofort zusammenklebt.
[Musik]
Und wenn der Zucker jetzt gleich aushärtet,
steht die Brille hoffentlich alleine
ohne Metallic Spray.
Ansonsten müssen wir Metallic Spray
mit in Harry Potters Geschichte einbauen.
Ja.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich hier das Logo
auf meine Hand legen vorsichtig.
Ich habe so Wachspapier jetzt dazwischen.
Dann kommt jetzt auf die Rückseite etwas Zuckerkleber
und ich klebe es hier an die Torte.
[Musik]
Woah, mit dem Rest kann ich so voll die Tupftechnik machen.
Wuh!
Schaut euch die Tupftechnik an!
Hier Reste.
Und dann legt ihr die so drauf.
Woah!
O mein Gott!
Das muss ich echt mal als krasse Tupftechnik benutzen.
Guck mal, wie cool das aussieht,
wie so Blattgold.
Ta-daa!
Ich glaube, das ist gerade so die coolste Stelle im Video.
[Musik]
Guck mal, wie cool!
Ha!
Voll der Schwabentrick!
Ich mache mal eine Hochzeitstorte so.
Sarah, darf ich irgendwann deine so machen?
>> SARAH: Du darfst meine Hochzeitstorte machen.
>> SALLY: Mit Klopapier?
>> SARAH: Ich will auf meiner Hochzeit singen
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: und fotografieren.
Darf ich dann auch bei deiner Hochzeit singen?
>> SARAH: Nein.
>> SALLY: Warum?
Ui! Da muss was drunter.
Seht ihr, wie die Torte rutscht?
Die rutscht da gleich runter.
Ah!
Eine Universaluntersetzer
– ein Universaluntersetzer.
Ach Mann!
Ich finde die Torte an sich auch schon ziemlich cool.
Oder?
>> SARAH: Ist gut.
>> SALLY: So als Harry-Potter-Fantorte.
Okay.
Gestern Abend war es zu spät.
Deswegen haben wir die Torte nicht mehr fertiggestellt.
Und außerdem konnte jetzt der Schnatz
über Nacht noch mal schön durchkühlen,
die Farbe trocknen.
Jetzt wird im Prinzip nur noch alles zusammengesetzt.
Also hier habe ich die Flügel vom Schnatz.
Hier muss ich den Draht etwas kürzen
und zwar,
ja, schon so bis da.
Ich habe Angst, dass er bricht.
>> SARAH: Soll ich eine Zange holen?
>> SALLY: Ja. Vielleicht eine Zange ist auch besser.
Kennst du das so, wenn du was machst
und dann weißt du eigentlich, dass es kaputt geht,
und dann machst du es trotzdem?
Und zack.
Okay.
>> JOSH: Ich glaube, manchmal will man einfach
eine Panne sehen.
>> SALLY: Ja, manchmal will man einfach,
dass was kaputt geht.
So wie hier die Brille.
So. Die ging nämlich über Nacht kaputt.
Ist aber gar nicht schlimm.
Denn
im Film ging Harrys Brille auch kaputt.
Also klebe ich die jetzt einfach zusammen
und mache so
so einen Streifen Blütenpaste drum.
Dann ist sie original wie im Film.
Zumindest im ersten Teil, gell, Josh?
Ich klebe es einfach jetzt hier zusammen.
Isomalt klebt alles.
Ei, ei, ei!
Volkan, das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Das ist jetzt mein Eigentum.
Die Werkstatt soll sich eine andere Zange holen.
[Musik]
Warum machen wir die Harry-Brille
nicht einfach komplett kaputt?
[Musik]
Dann hat er sich halt so sehr draufgesetzt,
dass halt gar nichts mehr ging.
Also im Shop ist der Volkan dann
für die Motivtorten zuständig.
Der hat die letzten drei Tage jetzt viel gelernt.
>> VOLKAN: Hm.
>> JOSH: Sag mal Hallo, Volkan.
>> VOLKAN: Hallo, Volkan.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: So.
Jetzt ist sie fertig.
Die gehört so.
Guck.
Ja.
So sah sie nach dem Unfall aus.
Jetzt müsste wieder Reporterin Sarah kommen:
"Auch in Sallys Welt läuft nicht immer alles glatt."
Das gehört so.
Ihr müsst es nur richtig verkaufen.
Okay.
Der goldene Schnatz, du musst jetzt funktionieren.
Da werde ich jetzt auch einfach Isomalt nehmen hier rein
und stecke dann
das Ganze ziemlich gerade rein
so wie bei dem Schnatz da hinten.
Wenn ihr es so macht,
dann kann es nämlich wirklich runterkrachen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt mache ich hier nur noch zwei Kugeln drauf.
Das hat nämlich der Schnatz da auch.
Und dann ist es fertig.
Dann kann es angerichtet werden.
[Musik]
Den muss ich aber reinstecken.
Sonst hält der nicht.
Ja, so zwei Zahnstocher
und der Schnatz.
[Musik]
Fertig!
So.
Und jetzt müssen nur noch alle drei gestapelt werden.
Nur noch.
Okay.
Jetzt kann ich die Torte stapeln.
Damit jetzt die oberen Torten die untere nicht eindrücken
durch das hohe Eigengewicht,
müsst ihr jetzt hier unten kleine Stäbchen reinstecken.
Schaschlikspieße reichen da nicht aus.
Ich nehme jetzt gleich Rundholz,
– das habe ich in der Garage –
muss es aber ausmessen.
Das ist praktisch
– wie beim Hausbau sind das so die Stützen,
die dann die obere Etage einfach halten.
Ansonsten
klappt nämlich alles zusammen
und es wird zerdrückt.
Ich mache jetzt
– hier nehme ich mir jetzt einmal das Maß.
Denn ich habe ja noch das Ganaching Board drunter.
Ihr könnt es auch ausmessen
und Ganaching Board abziehen.
Aber ich mache das jetzt hier so.
Das ist ein Lebensmittelstift.
Also keine Sorge.
Jetzt habe ich hier die Länge für die Dübel
für die untere Torte
und nehme jetzt hier, denke ich,
sieben Stück,
eins in die Mitte und sechs Stück außenrum.
Und dann messe ich jetzt gleich noch
die Höhe der mittleren Torte aus.
Die ist ein bisschen höher.
Da kann ich auch gleich Dübel zuschneiden.
[Musik]
Wenn ich die Torte jetzt transportieren würde von A nach B,
also von hier woandershin,
>> JOSH: Danke für die Erklärung.
>> SALLY: dann würde ich es auch so machen,
entweder vor Ort zusammenstapeln
oder ihr stapelt sie jetzt zusammen
und klebt es aber noch mal mit Ganache.
Und dann mache ich es aber meistens so,
dass ich keine Ganaching-Platte drunter habe,
sondern zum Beispiel eine Leichtschaumplatte.
Denn dann könnt ihr noch von oben nach unten
einmal so einen großen Dübel durchstecken,
damit die Torte nicht verschoben wird.
Aber ich würde es eher bevorzugen,
die Torten einzeln zu transportieren
und dann zu stapeln.
Ja, manche wissen vielleicht nicht, was von A nach B heißt.
Entschuldigung.
[Musik]
Mache ich Foto, tu ich Facebook.
Der Hut,
der sprechende.
Nein, Sally! Setz mich andersrum drauf!
So rum? Möchtest du so rum?
Nein, ich möchte nach vorne schauen!
So? So?
Ja, so gefällt mir das sehr gut.
So.
Wisst ihr, ich habe jetzt so lang
an der Harry-Potter-Torte gearbeitet,
ihr habt so lang darauf gewartet.
Da ist es doch klar, dass ich ein bisschen durchdrehe, oder?
So viel Druck aufgebaut.
Ich habe eigentlich gedacht, sie wird größer.
So.
Denke ich die ganze Zeit: "Was fehlt denn da noch?"
So, die Brille.
Die sieht vielleicht
– ah, nee. Da fällt sie runter.
Dann ist sie richtig kaputt, wenn sie da sitzt.
Der Schnatz, wo soll der hin?
>> SARAH: Auf den Hut?
>> SALLY: Auf den Hut?
Hier.
Und ich glaube, ich nehme aber noch so ein paar Steine
und verbinde sozusagen das untere
mit dem oberen Stockwerk.
Vielleicht tu ich sogar noch ein paar hier so drankleben.
[Musik]
Kommt, ihr zwei Harry-Potter-Kenner!
Siamak und Samira, ihr dürft probieren.
Ich glaube, jetzt würde gern jeder Zuschauer
mit euch tauschen wollen und einfach diese Torte probieren.
>> SIAMAK: Ich glaube auch.
>> SALLY: Okay. Also ich habe mir jetzt gedacht,
wir schneiden jetzt einfach mal den Hut an
hier.
Ich hoffe, es tut dem nicht weh.
>> SARAH: Ah!
>> SALLY: Ui, ui!
Ah!
>> SALLY: Ach!
>> SARAH: O Gott!
>> SALLY: Der arme Hut.
>> SARAH: Der Arme!
>> SIAMAK: Sieht aber so cool aus!
>> SALLY: Sieht cool aus, nicht?
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ist cool geworden.
Und, ich glaube, auch ziemlich lecker.
>> SAMIRA: Der Hut sieht so echt aus.
>> SALLY: Ich dachte eben so: "Was knuspert da?"
Aber ich habe ja Crunch reingebaut.
Das rutscht jetzt ein bisschen,
weil ich ja die Torte nicht geklebt habe.
>> SAMIRA: Was ist das für eine Torte?
>> SALLY: Also hier oben Schokolade.
>> SAMIRA: Unten?
>> SALLY: Und in der Mitte habe ich
Apple Crumble.
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und unten
Zimt mit Kirsche.
>> SIAMAK: Mmh!
Und oben Rice Crispie, oder?
>> SALLY: Oh, Siamak, bevor du die Torte probierst,
warte, ich muss noch was machen.
Du bist jetzt Harry Potter.
>> SIAMAK: Oh, okay.
>> SALLY: Weißt du, was kommt?
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
Dachte ich mir.
Passt es?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SIAMAK: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ja, das ist so ein bisschen an der Seite.
>> SIAMAK: Jetzt brauche ich nur noch eine Brille.
>> SAMIRA: Aber ich bin der einzig wahre Harry Potter.
>> SALLY: Ja, Samira ist der einzig wahre Harry Potter.
Zeig es ihm.
Und die kratzt manchmal, die Narbe, so:
Ah!
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Zeig es mal Siamak.
Ich finde es cool!
>> SIAMAK: Zeig mal.
Cool!
So was habe ich jetzt auch drauf, oder?
Du hast genau dasselbe.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Lehrer würden jetzt sagen:
"Nicht dasselbe, aber das Gleiche."
>> SIAMAK: Ah, das Gleiche. Ja.
>> SARAH: Streber aus Ravenclaw würden das auch sagen.
>> SALLY: Ah, doch Streber.
Oh!
Leckerschmecker, würde ich mal sagen!
>> SAMIRA: Sieht eigentlich ganz gut aus.
>> SALLY: Nur eig-
Nur eigentlich?
>> SIAMAK: Okay.
>> SALLY: Okay. Warte. Weil jetzt muss ich...
Um die anderen anzuschneiden,
muss ich natürlich die obere wegnehmen.
Vorsicht. Hier, stell mal kurz zur Seite.
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
>> SALLY: Genau. Hast du sie?
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: Okay. Dann mache ich kurz
sauber.
Also zum Anschneiden müsst ihr sie halt runternehmen.
Und die Stäbe, die könnt ihr dann entweder wegnehmen
oder einfach drumrumschneiden.
Das kann dann auch jeder Gast
oder jeder, der die Torte essen möchte.
>> SIAMAK: Mmh! Mit weißer Ganache, gell?
>> SALLY: Oh, lecker!
>> SIAMAK: Sieht sehr lecker aus.
>> SALLY: Oh, sollen wir so ein Bild machen?
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Hast du hier Blattgold benutzt?
Oder so was Ähnliches?
>> SALLY: Nee, der Papa wäre da stinksauer.
>> SAMIRA: Was dann?
>> SALLY: Komm. Dann nehmen wir die jetzt auch noch runter.
>> SAMIRA: Mama, was ist das?
Ah, ich weiß, wie du das gemacht hast!
Mit Zewa.
>> SALLY: Ja!
>> SARAH: Hast du das Video geguckt?
>> SALLY: Hast du schon das Video gesehen,
noch bevor wir es geschnitten haben?
>> SAMIRA: Nein.
>> SALLY: Ja, aber sie hat die Struktur erkannt
wahrscheinlich, nicht?
>> SAMIRA: Ja, weil da ein paar Kreise drauf sind.
Also so welche.
>> SALLY: Schlaues Kind! Schlaues Kind!
Okay.
Soll ich die weiter vorne anschneiden,
dass man das dann vorne sieht?
Das ist halt echt dann immer so.
Dann machst du so eine Torte
und dann zack,
>> SIAMAK: Ja, kaputt.
>> SALLY: kaputt.
>> SIAMAK: Aber das Reinschneiden ist immer so cool.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SIAMAK: Ich liebe das immer so, in Fondant so rein.
>> SALLY: Zack!
>> SIAMAK: Ja!
Da kann man den ganzen Tag zugucken.
>> SALLY: Satisfying.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: Da sind wir wieder bei unseren ASMR Videos.
Ui!
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Samira kennt sich aus.
>> SARAH: Oh!
>> SALLY: Wow!
>> SAMIRA: Die Schichten sehen so cool aus.
>> SALLY & SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SIAMAK: Das war Himbeer, oder?
>> SALLY: Kirsche.
>> SIAMAK: Ah, Kirche.
>> SARAH: Kirche?
>> SALLY & SAMIRA: Kirche!
>> SIAMAK: Ja, passend.
>> SAMIRA: Die heilige Kirche.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> SARAH: Wie sie dich verarscht!
Die heilige Kirche!
>> SALLY: So.
Soll ich euch einfach so eine Gabel von jedem geben?
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: Also
das hier ist die Schokotorte.
>> SIAMAK: Danke schön.
>> SALLY: Ich hole mir auch eine Gabel.
Ich glaube, so lang hat der Siamak noch nie
auf ein Tortenstück warten müssen, gell?
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und?
>> SIAMAK: Aber lohnt sich.
Was war noch mal drin?
>> SALLY: Schokolade.
>> SIAMAK: Und so Crunch.
>> SALLY: Salzbrezel.
>> SIAMAK: Und irgendwas Crunchiges noch, gell?
>> SALLY: Mandeln.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
Ah, lecker!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SIAMAK: Schokoladig.
>> SIAMAK: Die Äpfel passen gut, gell?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SIAMAK: Ich glaube, das ist mein Lieblingsstück,
>> SIAMAK: die Mitte.
>> SALLY: Und die Crumble,
die sind echt gut da drin, so keksig.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt hier.
>> SIAMAK: Und durch die Äpfel wird der Teig
auch voll weich in der Mitte,
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SIAMAK: bleibt es saftig.
>> SALLY: Und auf die Zimttorte bin ich jetzt auch gespannt.
>> SAMIRA: Ich glaube,
>> SALLY: Woah!
>> SAMIRA: ich finde
>> SIAMAK: Ich probiere auch ein kleines Stück.
>> SAMIRA: den Hut am besten,
danach
>> SALLY: Zimt?
>> SAMIRA: das mit Zimt
und mit der heiligen Kirche
und dann noch Apfel-Crumble.
>> SIAMAK: Ich finde die Mitte am besten,
>> SALLY: Ich auch.
>> SIAMAK: dann unten und dann oben.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Weil Schoko ist halt Schokokuchen, nicht?
>> SIAMAK: Ja, klar.
Aber hier ist es echt zimtig auch unten.
>> SALLY: Hm, zimtig.
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich finde auch Apple Crumble am besten.
>> SALLY: Aber alle drei sind gut, gell?
Auch schön saftig.
>> SIAMAK: Ja, auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: Guck mal. Heute ist bei uns Freitag.
Ich habe angefangen am Dienstag.
Weil bei uns
– wir machen die Fotos, die Videos und alles –
das dauert alles ein bisschen länger.
Normalerweise wäre ich auch schon
also locker nach zwei Tagen
– zwei volle Tage hätte ich gebraucht für alles.
Und es ist alles noch supersaftig und cremig.
Also die würde jetzt auch locker noch bis morgen halten.
Ja.
Echt cool!
Also ich hoffe,
dass euch die Harry-Potter-Torte gefällt.
Schreibt es gern in die Kommentare.
Falls ihr noch weitere Ideen habt,
schreibt sie auch in die Kommentare.
Wenn ihr wollt, dass ich zum Beispiel das Buch nachbacke
oder keine Ahnung welches Motiv,
schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Wir können ja die Harry-Potter-Reihe auch fortführen,
wenn es gut ankommt bei euch.
Und eigentlich wollte ich, dass wir...
>> SIAMAK: Den Hut aufsetzen?
>> SALLY: Das habe ich schon.
>> SIAMAK: Ah.
>> SALLY: Dass wir Murat als Hagrid verkleiden.
>> SIAMAK: Das war die Eule oder?
>> SALLY: Aber Hagrid ist halt so groß.
Nee.
>> SAMIRA: Oder...
>> SALLY: Das ist der, der Harry an seinem elften Geburtstag
geholt hat und gesagt hat, dass er ein Zauberer ist.
>> SIAMAK: Ach so, der mit dem Motorrad.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SIAMAK: Ja, okay.
>> SAMIRA: Oder...
>> SIAMAK: Aber Hagrid heißt doch auch die Eule, oder?
>> SALLY: Ich weiß nicht.
>> SARAH & JOSH: Hedwig.
>> SALLY & SIAMAK: Ah, Hedwig.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Oder...
>> SIAMAK: Ups!
>> SAMIRA: Oder Papa ist Hogmorph.
>> SALLY: Hogmorph?
Wer ist das?
>> SAMIRA: Der, der zwei Gesichter hat.
>> SALLY: Heißt der so?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SIAMAK: Wusste ich gar nicht.
>> SALLY: Echt?
Wie heißt der mit den zwei Gesichtern?
>> SAMIRA: Hogmorph.
>> SARAH: Mhm.
>> SAMIRA: Doch.
>> SARAH: Zwei Gesichter?
>> SALLY: Egal.
>> SARAH: Meinst du den auf dem Kopf hinten?
>> SAMIRA: Hier und hier.
>> SARAH: Das ist der Squirrel.
>> SAMIRA: Hä? Nein.
>> SARAH: Professor Squirrel. Doch.
>> SALLY: Ich bin da raus.
So gut kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Ich habe nur die Torte dazu gebacken.
Aber ich glaube, ich nehme es mir jetzt wirklich vor,
die Harry-Potter-Bücher zu lesen.
Und dann kannst du sie auch lesen, okay?
Ich verstehe kein Wort.
Nein, Josh nicht.
Ach Gott!
Okay. Also viel Spaß beim Nachbacken?
Backt die jemand nach?
Backt jemand eine Harry-Potter-Torte?
Wobei, ich finde schon,
so die einzelnen Torten kann man schon gut nachbacken.
Oder?
>> SIAMAK: Hm. Also von den Einlagen...
>> SALLY: Ja, nicht?
>> SIAMAK: Auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: Und auch so von einzelnen Motiven her.
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und ich denke, ich lade auch die Videos
noch einzeln hoch.
Wenn ihr zum Beispiel den Hut nachmachen wollt,
könnt ihr euch das Hutvideo anschauen.
Und so weiter.
Ja.
Also ich habe mein Versprechen eingelöst.
Ich hoffe, es gefällt euch.
Natürlich würde ich mich jetzt sehr freuen,
wenn ihr
– das sage ich jetzt, glaube ich, zum ersten Mal –
wenn ihr mein Video bewertet und es teilt.
Denn
ich hatte wirklich einen sehr großen Druck.
Also es hat sich über die Jahre hinweg viel Druck aufgebaut.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und ich habe sie immer so vor mir hergeschoben.
Aber ich finde, das Ergebnis lässt sich gut sehen.
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
>> SALLY: Hach!
>> SIAMAK: Sieht saucool aus.
>> SALLY: Also bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
>> SIAMAK: Tschüss!
Nur eine Frage habe ich
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SIAMAK: noch.
Was ist in dem Schatz drin?
>> SALLY: Im Schnatz sind Kuchenreste.
Das ist wie so eine Rumkugel.
>> SIAMAK: Okay.
Ich dachte, das wäre jetzt auch Rice Crispie.
>> SALLY: Ah, das hätte man auch machen können.
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
>> SALLY: Rice Crispie Treats.
>> SIAMAK: Cool.
>> SAMIRA: Ich bin ja Harry Potter.
Und in dem einen Harry-Potter-Film
hat der
ja das eine Ding da verschluckt.
>> SALLY: Den Schnatz.
>> SAMIRA: Und das werde ich jetzt auch gleich machen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> SIAMAK: Ich dachte immer, das heißt Schatz.
>> SALLY: Schnatz.
>> SIAMAK: Nee, Schnatz.
>> SAMIRA: Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es einen Namen hat.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Tschüss!
>> SIAMAK: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Jetzt machen wir eine fette Harry-Potter-Party.
Jetzt kann jeder Freunde einladen und Kuchen essen.
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
[Musik]